[Music]
if i could dream a dream
and dream so deeply that i
wouldn't have to wake up
oh i'd be the only one that you'd call
baby and i wouldn't have to feel lonely
after we fall
[Music]
what's up everyone zeb
[Music]
it's also the vibe with i'm so grateful
evan bliss was
[Music]
he is good people yes and a good person
yes and we have
the optimal i would say
first los angeles
up-and-coming artist on the shows oh is
that me that's you oh really because
evan
evan was our first show okay and he was
we did a lot of and then also we have a
little bit
of some cool software to be able to kind
of demo and show you
some of uh his more
nuanced technicalities to the actual
production of
stuff right so we'll be showing you that
as well pumped
zeb we love to start things off with
journeys
walk yes well i know i know this is
an intense one for my brothers i'm ready
i'm ready
um yeah so there's there's get pumped
okay
journey stuff uh we had a little
uh birth to 18 we had in steamboat
colorado
right so well so i was actually born in
if you can imagine a place called
boon that's exactly what it is like if
you
it's so actually finally that's actually
a good place to start
actually um i was just in colorado for
my grandmother's um
memorial service and it was the night
before the thing and
me and my cousin uh like pretty
emotional dudes and like
it and she was a really big deal she was
like the matriarch of the family she
kind of like held everything together
um and we were drinking you know like we
were like huh dude not looking forward
to tomorrow kind of in a way you know
because it's it's
we're preparing for like the sadness of
it all um and he was like we just got to
keep going like
stay with like come to my house let's do
pool or whatever like i just got to stay
up i don't want to be alone
and i was like dude i really should get
to bed like you know i'm playing a song
at the memorial service i kind of had to
be on point for the pa and stuff to help
out
and um he's like i'll make you a deal
i'll take you to the house you were born
in
if you stay up with me so he and he see
and he's really good on that kind of
stuff so he drove me
all the way to like and i've been
putting that off for years like i just
kind of
because i knew it you know like i was
actually born in this house and um
you know at the time like some of the
exterior walls weren't even finished and
stuff like super super
ratchet like just super ghetto um so
i've been putting it off but i kind of
knew i should go
like revisit that space but i was only
there for
i don't know three months probably
before we moved to steamboat but
so technically born in boone which again
looks exactly
how it sounds and then steamboat springs
was
you know where i kind of cut my teeth
and stuff so walk us through
the journey of growing up and then how
you
even got interested in the north star of
music production okay yeah
so um there was always a guitar around
the house so i started playing guitar
when i was about six
so i kind of always knew i wanted to do
music um
but yeah the my up
you know my home life and like how i was
raised was like
really tricky because we were super poor
and steamboat's like this super affluent
community right it's a
ski resort you know in the rocky
mountains beautiful like paradise
basically um but you know i was
raised in a trailer park and you know
our trailer court just happened to be
like
kind of the the rough you know like the
weirdest one where like
them you know everyone seemed to be
alcoholics there's like a lot of
um you know domestic abuse and it's just
it's like super super weird
um but yeah it was it was tricky like
trying to get through that and navigate
it
um was hard and like it really you know
i struggled with depression
and and it was just it was a really ugly
situation
and like i was telling you that story
about like my first car for instance
so i'm working a good store so i'm
working at this restaurant
and i always worked really hard you know
i always had like a work ethic and i had
a lot of like
pride in wanting to you know um
kind of prove myself like i'm not my
circumstances i'm better than that or
something
um anyway so my boss is like dude you're
the best like you're
the coolest you always kick ass um
i will you know like i heard you've been
having trouble like getting to band
practice and stuff
and i was like yeah it's been tough like
you know and he was like well listen i
have a car that's
in my field you know like you see like
he lived on a ranch or whatever he's
like if you can get this car to start
it's yours
and so i got out there and like sure
[ __ ] we like figured out how to get it
going and um it was a 1984
caprice classes like body by fischer
like maven old school kind of
thing and of course i could put like
this great stereo system in it and i
like
spray painted brown betty on the hood
and like named it and like kind of made
a joke out of the fact that it was like
a piece of
[ __ ] and like i was going to school with
kids that literally had
one of these kids at our school had five
different cars like inc you know
including like a cherried out old you
know chevy and then he had like a
defender 90.
you know he had like you know he had an
audi the whole thing and which is fine
you know like
um stark wealth inequality
it was just i think that's just tricky
for
like as a kid like is it you know
because everything's the end of the
world when you're a kid
you know and it really hurts your
feelings when you're like
driving you know like i'm literally
driving out of this trailer park in the
shitty car like
to this you know this symbol of like
affluence which is this beautiful ski
mountain
every morning like and that's how i
start my day just being like [ __ ]
like this is embarrassing like i'm going
closer and closer like
further and further away like into this
you know um community i kind of had
nothing
to do with like i was like this third
class citizen there you know and like we
weren't all in it together you know like
um
i got along with everyone pretty well
but it was hard you know it was hard to
just like
get invited to a party and show up and
be like and then go back home
to this and be like [ __ ] man this is
rough like this is uh
yeah it was like you know it messes with
your ego a lot it messes with like
you know and what is it all about and
like yeah anyway so
tricky there um and definitely started
getting into like
you know really lashing out like super
bad behavior again i was saying i'd
struggle with depression and stuff um
and it manifests in a lot of bad ways
you know definitely abusing alcohol i
was you know selling drugs you know
mostly uh cannabis or whatever um
some other stuff there you know breaking
and entering like it was
it was i definitely got to a very dark
spot and thankfully
music really like pulled me out of it
and that that was the hugest pieces like
i finally
you know i was in this band um that we
kind of formed a middle school and
and i and i knew i really wanted to do
music but i think
there was always this attitude too of
like i want to figure out how to make
money and i think that's where a lot of
the
bad behavior came from was like okay if
maybe if i can sell enough drugs then
i can get a new car or like or i can get
the music gear i want or you know
and and i always did again i always had
that like hustle mentality and i worked
a lot of straight jobs too
and i made pretty decent money doing
that but i was always
you know i think the volume was turned
down so much from just seeing some of
the stuff i saw the trailer park with
you know literally just like people
getting knocked around in like broad
daylight
and stuff um that and i felt so like
uncomfortable a lot
that like moving into doing those really
bad behaviors wasn't that big of a leap
you know it was almost like a
comfortable thing almost because i was
already so uncomfortable anyway
um so when it came to like oh i could
use that to my advantage like i'm not
afraid of any of this
and maybe i can get some money out of it
and then maybe i can like close that gap
that discrepancy between you know these
um
people that you know the haves and the
me being like i have not like
maybe i can be more on their level if i
can
you know figure out some scheme but
anyway one of my favorite
aspects to all of the guests that we've
interviewed is there's
a pattern there's an archetype of of
trauma to treasure in essence and it's
we talk about this in high-level
perception chapter 2c theory a lot
that the more that at times that these
roots reach down to hell like carl jung
said that
the more that the fruits can reach up to
the heavens and so
you have this very interesting
bifurcation that occurred
in your life as so many people have
where there was this moment where you
could potentially see
yourself in your possibility space
have ended up more in the lines of
being involved with things that are less
fruitful for yourself your family your
community the world at large
but you had this star of of music
production which kind of you know kind
of
you gravitate towards that and you like
that that lights the fire under your
butt more
and then so how did you end up
figuring out that it was you know you
said you had the guitar
at home yeah so there was kind of this
constant music vibe in a sense
is that kind of what yeah like well and
again i feel like honestly i've always i
always knew i wanted to do music and i
think that was another
thing of like okay maybe this is a
scheme where i can like
at a middle school and i was starting to
get into high school but i came out of
middle school with
some really intense experiences like we
were talking about
like these these situations where life
gets super real and like
i use the word like hot or like it feels
like really crazy and you're like oh my
god
especially when you're getting in
trouble right so i think
i had enough of those experiences
especially
um broke into this house we were
stealing
guns and i had a gun in my hand and i'm
standing in someone else's house
and it was crazy like it just i was like
how is this my life how
how is this even like what is this like
why is this my life you know it felt
like a movie or something
and we're leaving and i hear a noise and
i'm like and then all of a sudden i'm
like it's almost like an automatic odd
out of body experience where i'm like
watching myself pull this gun
and you know potentially kind of like
super hurt myself
hurt someone else like there's nothing
good about it and i think
um i think that was one of those moments
where i was like
holy like that feels terrible like i
never like that's so and it was really
helpful because it was like
okay anytime there's any inkling of that
feeling it's like run the other
direction like and it kind of it was
like
it was a kind of a reset like i kind of
feel like there's a new part of me that
like came online
because of that like really intense
feeling
you know and like we were saying earlier
like it almost felt like i was on drugs
like i've never smoked crack but it felt
like i'm like imagining that's what it
oh my god like just like in just like
everything sounds weird or feels weird
like
whew and like just adrenaline like pure
adrenaline like just
way too like od on adrenaline right um
very clear
bifurcation in that scenario where you
can literally see the path to hell and
the path to heaven
to suffering into well-being also well
that's a really interesting way to put i
never even thought of it that way but i
think you're right it's almost like
maybe that sensation is almost like what
it feels like to peer down those things
like and and really be like okay what is
it what is it gonna be like you have to
decide right now
you know like and then it's like this
split moment thing luckily
nothing happened and it's crazy to me
like i've never been arrested
i've never like nothing has ever really
gone wrong like no one died and you know
no one ever really got hurt around me
like there's never been something really
really terrible
which like so lucky i feel like
considering all the crazy
[ __ ] i've done so yeah anyway so i got
out of that and i think that was yeah
this was that was like a big moment of
like okay
let's do let's do this music thing let's
like focus on
these positive things in my life and you
know
and make this happen like get out of
here because it was like a nightmare
kind of lifestyle like always nervous
like there was just like a block of ice
in my stomach
like hated going home hated going to
school always
you know just uncomfortable and sad and
scared and angry it was like
so it was like okay how do i get out of
this and then every time i would get
sucked into music
it took me in this like i was you know
it was kind of an escape it literally
you know i was like reaching into this
this
you know wherever all the songs are i
was like reaching into that place and
grabbing songs and like
being there was so much better than
being where it was
and so i just kept focusing on that and
pushed really hard ended up getting into
berkeley and then
that was kind of the big relief is like
getting to boston let's yes okay so
let's
let's uh let's unpack so we have
we have you also were talking about this
before we started i love this a lot
it's this sort of the story
isn't told so often about someone that
really has is immersed in a shitty
like a hard really hard upbringing of
lots of suffering
and that is able to do that imaginative
envisioning
of a north star that can that can
basically
suck them draw them out light the fire
under their butt to get them
out of the suffering scenario and that
then they can in a sense
achieve these higher level fruits that
they can
use for themselves their family their
community to kind of uplift more and
more people be an example
i love that and then for you that ended
up being the berkeley college of music
in boston kind of as your next music
production
step yeah and i think and i was finally
out right like i finally
like made it out i figured out a way to
get out of there and and it was for a
good reason and it felt like it made
sense it wasn't just you know whatever
like it wasn't it wasn't like a shift to
the side it was like literally an
upgrade but yeah i think i think
um just to speak on what you're just uh
talking about i think
yeah that one i think a lot of credit
needs to be given to people that
can do like can just get out of the
situation they're in
because it does it takes it takes being
a visionary
i mean i think you have to be able to
imagine whatever the goal you have
if you can visualize it like if you can
make it happen in your mind
then you can make it happen and
something is you know simple
is getting out of the trailer park or
getting out of the hood
i think people need a lot of credit for
that because and i think it takes the
same you know it's that same skill
of like being able to create you know
disney world
envisioning this crazy thing and like
actually having it finally come to
fruition i mean after he passed but
still like
that that ability is it's the same thing
that's the same ability that creates
anything is you know is being able to
think at first
and let that take over your actual
reality and manifest and
and it's no small feat and i think
encouraging people to do that
and giving people credit and kind of
normalizing the fact that that stuff has
happened to a lot of people i think
like every time i tell these stories
there's always a part of me that's like
man
it there's it's coming some stigma
that's going to be attached to it people
might look at me different
um and i'm sure some people do but i
think it's super um
you know take a disservice to themselves
to do that to look at me different
because of my past
there's a whole suite of other people
that look at you more authentically as
well
and also people that become more
comfortable with them themselves sharing
their stories and trajectories
and traumas that have been birthed
treasures well one i really think that
inspiration in that sense we'll get one
i hope so and i think um
you know not to my own horn or whatever
like i mean there's people that have way
worse situations that have come way
further
but just encouraging that and not
stigmatizing those people that's like
the bet like
loving like like you know like and i
think it's so sad when the opposite of
that happens
um and yeah people need to be really
careful about that and like
i see it all the time where it's like oh
well you know don't hang out with that
person or like oh don't you know be
around that or whatever
um you know and even phrases where
people are like oh well if you
hang out with um all these people that
have a certain net wealth that's gonna
tell you what like
amount of money you're gonna end up with
and i understand that in theory
i do and i think yeah of course you want
to be around people that are helping
bolstering you up and not pulling you
down
but i think it's also really important
that we love the people that
need love and sometimes you know the
people that maybe even deserve
love the least are the ones that need it
the most and you know in
you know being friends with your enemy
kind of like all that like
um acceptance of other people and like
just giving
space and caring about people that might
not be at your level or whatever and
and hoping that they want to better
themselves
and not condemning them you know and
yeah anyway so
when i tell those stories it's always a
little uncomfortable but it's like i
kind of feel like i should because i
know there's a lot of other people
that and everyone has their struggle and
that's okay too like that's another part
of it is like at whatever level even if
you're you know
super grow up super affluent like some
of the kids in steamboat that
did have the most like privilege or
whatever some of them had like the
hardest
path you know because it was you know
because they had their own set of crazy
stuff that they had to work through
you know and anyway thanks for bringing
up all that
nuance to it because it is it is that
multivariate
now when you when you find yourself
because i think a lot of
the people that we've interviewed that
have went to the berkeley college of
music have been attempting to sort of
break down
why it's so profound um a lot of people
don't
know because they're not really like
polymathic and trying to like
dive into the us's best music schools
um right so my
sort of idea would be
unpack why because berkeley's so
interesting because like as we've
interviewed people from there it's not
just
you know music production you also have
people that are doing crazy things like
mixed reality
like xr type stuff vr ar and
music at the same time so wakkas yeah
and how profound that was
yeah yeah so it's pretty simple i think
um the easiest way to
break down berkeley or talk about why
it's a special place is um
i mean it's there should be more places
like it actually but um basically it's
the premier music college
for contemporary music on the planet
like there's nothing else that even
comes close to it because most schools
are either you know juilliard you're
going to be doing jazz
classical and fantastic school obviously
um
berkeley is super focused on what's
cutting edge and
you have to have you know and they have
a lot of interesting rules like you have
to have
a principal instrument and and
everything's about
making like modern music
so the focus is a lot different and the
capabilities all there right like
because you do
have people doing music production and
engineering you have all these studios
everywhere
different shapes and sizes and you know
in practice rooms everywhere so it's
just like this
crazy you know and you do have great
jazz musicians and classical musicians
as well and they do that but it's like
everyone's together and like mixing all
these
different genres together and all their
different skills together
um so it's really like crazy how it
like just being in there was nuts and
and and it was there's a lot of good
stuff about it but there's also a lot of
bad stuff about it for me because i
definitely
was super intimidated i don't feel like
i had the tools to like really
get as much out of it as i could have
because i just came off of like
you know like literally being you know
like my whole universe was flipped
upside down i went from living in a
trailer to living on one of the most
expensive streets in the world like i
was on commonwealth avenue she's like
gorgeous like
every place next to me was like a
million dollar flat um
which was like a dream come true is
really cool but again it was just like
holy [ __ ] you know like in it and i
think it hit me with like oh you're not
good enough and like so my
depression actually ramped up a lot i
think
in high school i was kind of in revenge
mode and like i was
motivated to like you know to fight the
system back kind of or something and
then when i hit
berkeley i think my depression kind of
went into full swing so that was
interesting too it was like
there was a lot of good stuff about it
but it was so hard for me to like i was
still pro or i was just
finally processing all this stuff right
because i finally had like separation
from
that space so yeah anyway it was
interesting but yeah
the the point on the school is just that
it's just
um i think it's just so much more
forward thinking than any other college
i mean
i know belmont has a songwriting degree
berkeley has a songwriting degree
i think there might be like one other
new college that has that
that's that's the degree i have but you
know there's not a lot of places you can
go to get these things
and i think they did a they did a
relatively good job i mean
college is way too expensive and that's
like a welder conversation but
i think his colleges go um they had a
lot of great faculty
you know they had some duds too i mean
everyone does but um but yeah i think
it's a really special place just because
of the facilities
and and really i think the biggest thing
is the students it attracts
like that's the huge it appears the
people i met there
outweigh anything my professors ever
said outweigh any studio time i ever got
it was like those kids like some of the
kids i've gotten to interact with and
collaborate with
those are the ones that like i was like
okay it's like st
and again those were some hot moments
too like way more positive
and less like terrifying yeah but
definitely like
okay are you gonna step up your game or
like are you
gonna like are you gonna jump in with
the with the wolves are you gonna go
chill
you know and like just kind of sit back
you know like and again everyone
makes their choices on that stuff but i
definitely was you know
but you know and i got scared away a few
times there was a few like oh yeah
there's a few teams i couldn't get into
right there's a few like you know what i
mean yeah yeah because some of them you
know
super high level oh my god yeah he's
like as competitive as a good kid
you know and people getting like pulled
out of their during their college career
to like go be
you know on the professional level like
all the time you know so you'd be like
oh he left
like yeah he's on tour with so and so i
was like oh my god wow yeah
so yeah so that's literally like an
analogy to
when you're playing
basketball at the collegiate level oh
totally drafted right into the nba
yeah absolutely one it's funny i think
well and i kind of get in trouble for
this a lot but i do
i think um music um
in terms of yeah i compare musicians and
music
to to sports a lot more than that well a
lot of people are like well no but it's
so different and it's like
yeah but you know they're like and
they're like who's the best and i'm like
who made the most baskets you know like
everyone's like who's the best musician
i'm like
i don't know i mean i kind of have to go
with jay-z like he's
he's michael jordan he made the most
baskets like he just crushed it i don't
know and
again you can have your subjective
opinion about it but like objectively
like if you had to like make a case i'm
like
you know everyone was like oh but it's
not like that because music and it's
creative and i'm like
what kind of way is that like i don't
know what to tell you you know
you can't even play
uh and i want more people to analogize
uh music with sport because art
is sport and sport is art and i and i i
like not i i like holding them
as separate and i like holding them as
one
at the same time like we have to be able
to hold like in a very
metaphysical way we talk about this a
lot like you have to be able to hold
the oneness of everything at the same
time as you hold your individuality
right and so that's you have to be
simultaneous when you make these
analogies and things so you can keep
music and sports separate and you can
blend them together
into a synthesis at the same time yeah i
think they're super comparable and i
think i think that's why i like hip-hop
so much is because
they embrace that like they embrace the
competition of it and they
and they reference each other which i
think is super cool like i think that
should happen more
other music um you know the all the
existentialists did that you know they
would all like kind of poke fun at each
other and like
you know it was like it was you know and
i think that i don't know i think to me
that's really really cool
um and yeah it's funny when people are
like oh you're biting my style and stuff
it's like that should be a compliment to
you like if someone's like
influenced by you or whatever and and
like and what a kind of like loser
mentality thing to
say like if someone was biting my style
like once and if i get
my style established and they do
something
you know i think the only response i
would want to have is like
do like kind of and then go back like
crush them hard and be like okay that's
okay i see what you're doing there and
then just
you know just like drop drop something
that kind of
pushes back to be like okay like now the
ball's in your quarter again let's go
like in
yeah and there's and i think that's a
cool thing like i think that's a good
thing but
it's mimesis it's combinatorics
it's you know somebody taking what you
made
and adding their creative spin
and then you being grateful that
somebody recognized how cool of a thing
you made
and then somebody else adds their spin
on it and you analyze that
you add your own spin it's like this
never-ending process
of people becoming more and more
artistic
and uh expressing themselves and that's
what it is like that's just what it is
like that's how stuff grows too like
that's a really interesting
way for things to grow and for us to
push each other and
and i mean and it's just and it's so
funny when people like think that that
is very much like dna
as well how it has well and just i mean
just like the simple fact that we are
standing on the shoulders of the people
that came before us
no matter what you do and it's like i
didn't invent the guitar so it's like i
can't
you know everyone's like well isn't that
like cheating or is it you know like
with different techniques or like
sampling music friendships
this big one it's like it's like are you
are you kidding me like
let's just keep let's just keep going
like just keep stacking on top of each
other like why are we trying to be like
well wait a second like i'm gonna call
foul here it's like nah just keep just
go
just run to the to the next thing
because you know it's
we're not gonna run out like there's
this infinite thing and trying to get
that
next awesome surprising sound or like
you know like even breaking a new genre
like that's possible
but it's not going to happen if we're
all like trying to you know hold each
other back like crabs in a bucket you
know yeah stupid
anyway let's um let's ramp in because
we did um on berkeley college of music
uh you're having this
really enriching flowering experience
that also had its own roots and shadow
at the same time
and you saw these paths of like the pros
getting like drafted into the nba and
like stuff like that
and so you kind of like you know saw
your star becoming more and more
kind of um unveiled like you saw it
appearing more and more of where your
trajectory and so
when exactly did the transition happen
from boston to los angeles
and um and then how did that transition
lead you
into the production of true north which
was your ep
okay sure so um basically
i was trying to make bands work
throughout berkeley um
after berkeley i was in a band called
morning old sport we got signed to a
record label in colorado we went out
there
we recorded but but basically my whole
berkeley
experience was like peppered with
failure you know like i never got
drafted i never you know like i never
was quite there i was never able to
quite get a band off the ground in
boston
we went to do this thing in colorado
that like imploded on itself because we
were all living together in this like
crazy mansion it was amazing
we had a 24 hour lockout to this
ridiculous studio
and like with the other lead singer
like they wanted to play cards for six
hours a day and like
record like two and which is fine like
again i was like shoot but it just
again i didn't know how to cope with it
i didn't know how to deal with it and
that's really
the the first time i was like heavily
relying on my own production
to like stay sane so i set up
my computer in my room and when you know
people were messing around and doing
their thing
i was just trying to like focus on okay
so how do i
how do i figure out how to do this so i
don't need to rely on anyone basically
yeah
and and i think the other thing is i can
like easily blame people or whatever but
the fact of the matter is um i didn't
know how to cope with it
i could have obviously been a better
communicator but at the end of the day
like band dynamics i could i just never
was able to figure it out
so that helped push me you know in on
myself
being in that studio working by myself
like starting to really develop
some of these skills that was huge thing
implodes
um moved home to steamboat for a while
i was living at this really cool house i
actually had a cool studio set up there
that was feeling good
progress progress progress then
i call up my buddy from berkeley this
kid matt weber who's amazing
and i was like hey can you mix this song
and he's like no
i want to produce with you like we need
to make like this is amazing like listen
to this thing i'm building and i was
like i didn't even know you were
producing it now and he's like yeah yeah
like let's do this
so he's actually who got me into ableton
cool yes i was in logic which is a daw
um it's like a you know what you build a
musical audio workstation
right yeah yeah okay so um so logic is
one
daw and ableton is a different song yeah
it's
yeah so and they're all pretty the same
you know like pro tools it's just
it's just whichever software you're
working in and um anyway he was in
ableton at the time
and he's he was like what do we do you
know because we weren't going to try to
do cross-platform and i was like you
know what i think i want to learn
ableton like let's go that direction and
it was really cool because he had
you know he'd already built up this
really awesome workflow and stuff so i
was able to pick it up really fast
um and we were like screw it like let's
move in together so i moved to la first
um
just because i knew i'd want to be there
i didn't want to like stay in colorado
too long
which it was nice to be there though for
a second it was like nice to like get us
i was like oh this like huge thing i
thought was gonna go
didn't go and i was like ah dang it and
then but it was nice i like gotta kind
of lick my wounds and then i was like
okay i'm ready to go back out so i'm
in l.a me and matt are passing things
back and forth
he's in new york i go visit him out
there
we have a really good time he comes out
here we have a really good time and then
he's like you know what i'm ready to
leave like i love new york but i'm like
it's time so he moved out here and we
tried
and we got really really close and
actually some of the songs on the ep
were we started together you know so
like he has a lot of credit on this
album and like we really developed that
yeah it was really nice and like what an
awesome teammate but again
it was like the band dynamic stuff like
we couldn't quite work it out it was
definitely like
the best breakup yeah yeah i mean like
it was like
so like yeah it was definitely like way
better communication and stuff but it's
still it's still hard
and it won't it's you know because it's
it's so emotional it's like you're
marrying this person right so
and you're like and you keep being you
know and every day you're like here's my
soul and they're like
what if we do that you know you know
like it's it's like it's very it's it's
tricky like it's a tricky tricky thing
um and especially you know when you're
struggling and there's not there's no
budget
and you know what i mean and no one's
getting paid so it's like you know
there's some resentment that can happen
it's just tough it's tough so
that falls apart um or you know that we
we decided to go our separate ways and
then that's when everything kind of
really clicked in like
i like as that was happening i kind of
finally
got a hold of this last workflow thing
and then i was like oh this is this is
going to work like this is a path like
now i know how to get
from point a to point b and that's in
the first thing that kind of let me know
that was the song plane
which is still probably the best song on
the album or you know like or you got
the best attention so
yeah right so that was like the first
thing i was like okay this is how i'm
going to do it
and and i think
yeah that song kind of made me realize
like that kind of like instigated the
like
i need to move on because there just
wasn't any room
in that process for someone else yeah
and that process was
very much me reaching into myself
and just trusting that so like that's
what really like
changed everything and i think that's
why i wanted to call the album true
north is because it was like
if i can just remember this that's all i
need i just have to remember to
like really reach in and like
in 100 trust whatever i find out there
and you know and just remember that
again
it also helped push the theory i had and
like kind of solidify it more
that i think all the songs are out there
and they're finished and i'm not someone
that
creates stuff i'm someone that discovers
things
and so reaching was like a lot easier to
do
when i was untethered to anything else
and i didn't have to answer anyone or
collaborate with anybody i just
went yeah um and now collaborating is
really fun but it's still like
you know based off of a platform of
something i've already found and like
it's just easier to manage when it's
like my solo project
so the collaborating becomes it's like a
lot less of course
yeah there's a lot there's a lot less
weight to it it's just fun and like it
just adds something nice and like it
doesn't have to be
and if it doesn't work it doesn't matter
you know it's not like this oh we have
to make this work as a team you know
whatever so
but yeah that that was that was a huge
moment but
that's really what pushed me toward and
i always felt like i had that sense like
i always knew like oh yeah like and i've
always had that theory like oh we don't
i remember talking about this in college
like oh well it's like all the songs are
done and you gotta find them and like i
remember
but when i really was doing it
at this like different level all of a
sudden that that that happened during
plane
well i'll never forget that night i was
like in this you know i finally had my
room was like sounding a lot better i
did some like treatment um me and matt
were like kind of deciding maybe we
wouldn't work together anymore
and i just went into like this other
world
like and then i was like okay that like
if i just got to keep doing that over
and over
yeah but it's so trial and error you
know like and again i had this theory
that it would work
and then yeah it was kind of like yeah
like speaking like a visionary kind of
thing right it was like
i envisioned this thing of me like going
into another planet
and then and then i finally arrived
there and you know sure [ __ ]
there was a that was like the best song
i've ever i was like oh there it is
there's the song okay
i wasn't crazy like yeah it proved the
theory a little bit for me you know like
but anyway yeah yeah wow yeah i really
like
how you you in a sense you kind of like
you
anchored true north
as your corner stone
that you could always come to as your
first like pivotal i love to use
cornerstone because like on the cover
there's this rock formation right that's
literally behind my sister's house
and and i had this really cool
conversation with my sister's husband
and because he was born there he was
born right and like it was so crazy
his parents house is like right here and
the house right next to them goes on the
market and it's like perfect it was like
perfect for the film perfect size
perfect
lot everything so he literally bought
their like their second home is
literally walking distance from where he
was
raised yeah and it's like it's so
beautiful and the kids get to be there
and like
they have a little sledding hill
whatever so awesome so we were talking
about it and he's like
you know we thought about maybe buying a
house in steamboat or different places
but needle rock always meant so much to
me because my dad always said
no matter what happens like you come
back here
like this is the spot like you know like
x marks the spot like this rock
is our yeah wow yeah and it was like
that hit me like i'll never that like i
was like oh my god like everybody just
like hit me with an
arrow in my heart and it was just like
pouring i was just like god it's so
beautiful like
it's like yeah it's hard to even like
say it because it chokes me up but i
love it
it's so big yeah it's just so beautiful
one and i think so that's cool that was
it's called needle point needle rock
needle rock right and you know rock is
the rock that's on the true north album
cover
right so yeah so yeah so i wanted to
integrate that because
because of that conversation and because
you know it x marks the spotter
right they come back right and i think
and they're such a you know and that's a
similar thing
right and like and that's and i feel the
same way with music right if i ever lose
my way
i just have to remember to go to that
place and grab
you know like get inside myself like
really go to that
that spot and i feel like yeah i do i
feel like i was like
you know on the moon and like
you know putting a flag like okay don't
just remember
where that flag is if you ever get lost
so um so yeah there's
definitely a um a similarity between
those two things but i think the other
reason
why that rock thing hits me so hard is
just because like i think that was
something i always lacked as a kid
and it's so cool to hear him like
describe it because he had that and
he was like offering it to me you know
he's like this is ours now
like you're part of this family and like
this is your rock too yeah and i was
like oh thank god
you know like i kind of feel like i have
a home exactly you know
beautiful yeah big i'm i'm a huge fan of
the word cornerstone
i put it in the chapter 2c theory and
high-level perception that
in that sort of first compound zone of
the seed the human being birthed into
the world
and in the first couple of years those
sort of moments that are so pivotal
those are cornerstone moments and if you
can anchor
in a sense your
artistic essence as a cornerstone in an
album
to you what your
ep is north star um
as yours is kind of like um
you know your true north your north i
call it north star
um what my kind of north star anchor
point in a sense is for me
is high level perception this artistic
synthesis that i just made that i'm
always kind of trying to like
come back to and put frank so it's so
beautiful in a sense like being able to
to make these really artistic
expressions of our soul
and as anchor points as cornerstones
yeah well and i think
when i think it's such a um it's such a
profound
thing for you know for everyone to you
know and everyone says it different but
like i really you know i went on this
thing and
i had this uh trip and i found myself
and i think to me
how i translate that is what you're
really finding
is your entry point into every you know
like you're finding
your way of getting into tapping into
all this [ __ ] you know like to be
you know you're you're finding your
doorway into
connecting with everything because so
many people describe it the same way
they're like once i
found myself i realized you know i'm i'm
not that important but i am you know
like i'm just
part of this whole thing and so yeah
and i always push on people like what do
you mean by when you found yourself and
like almost every time it's some you
know it's some
version of explaining well now i feel
like connected with everything and now i
feel like i'm a part of this place yes
and so to me like yeah finding your in
it and that's the thing it's it's so
specific everyone has their
own entry point and until you find that
like it sucks
like it's not you know it's it's a hard
place to be so so in
in the symphonic consciousness analogy
that we talk about in high level
perception would be something along the
lines of like
the the individual's
gateway into both feeling like they're a
part of the
symphony that's unfolding of the unity
as well as
the individual truly truly figuring out
what their unique instrument and melody
are in the symphony and that's kind of
that's the gateway moment for them
finding themselves
yeah i think when i think it's just yeah
that process of becoming great
like that possible that process of
trying to find your greatness or find
your yes
or whatever your highest value you know
however you want to put it but that that
thing that like
yeah you're kind of here to do i suppose
exactly you know it's your icky guy
yeah again and again like this is all
just i don't
know anything like i always want to
preface like i don't know nothing you
know like
this is a video these are just an
archetype
well but it's important it's like i you
know these are just my ideas right
these are just thoughts like i'm not
trying to pretend like i'm you know like
this could apply to anyone else i'm
strictly saying i think this it applies
i personally think it applies to
pretty much well i hope it does every
everyone because
i i made a hypothesis in chapter two on
my little perception which is that the
north star perception what we're talking
about this ikigai this true north
basically
the idea is that it is it plays a
fundamental role in the nature of
reality so the individual
uncovering their own unique artistic
expression
may even be one of the most fundamental
um parts to the nature of consciousness
and the nature of reality the nature of
creativity
and so it is most i think almost
certainly
a fundamental role so we unpacked true
north
we played um we played the first song
of hindsight um and we have
another um song that we want to play
music
yeah yeah and so and so though and you
might have to reach back because
obviously we played that song at the
beginning but
yes i think the purpose of us playing
that particular song was
um it's gonna kind of help us get into
the next topic of just
how the album is gonna play out and then
also
um kind of the future of music or these
ideas about how
music technology is changing so much so
the first song was straight up recorded
like
in a living room everyone's playing at
the same time no auto-tune
no you know you know like we obviously
obviously mixed it to the best of our
ability but
i think we had like five microphones
like you know like sm58
just like just bare bones like whatever
we had we just put it up
went for it um and
in in that provided um like a cool
beginning for me to the album because
that was actually a song i recorded
with morning old sport like all that
time ago
and it just never quite ended up making
it on
the album um that we recorded in
colorado
at fancy studio um and i was like you
know what this is perfect
like i should i should kind of start
here and um
and i think it's a nice structured
position because again you're going to
kind of hear
what you know very little music
technology sounds like and then
kind of the depth or the other direction
you can go when you have all the tools
that i have now
may i also just make a you know
at the very beginning of uh like it or
not you have
the the definition of hindsight right
what's super interesting is that um i
have this
also this quote in chapter three of high
level perception
which is the edge where i write because
it's like the edge
of civilization's knowledge and that
when we're birthed
that we want to rock it out to the edge
and artistically express our self plant
flags beyond the edge
test them with hypotheses artistically
push the edge
and so you know galileo i had this quote
in there too
that it's that all
truths are easy to understand once they
are discovered
the point is to discover them yeah and
so
hindsight is very deeply related to that
that's what we understand
people look and they're like you know i
say it's always 20 20. i look back in it
you know steve jobs also has a really
profound quote where he says that
when he looks back on his life all of
the connecting dots
makes sense yeah and it's hard when
you're in the middle of the journey
to be able to see that but i would
challenge you to try
and as much as you can both live in the
moment
and also live as much as you can in the
entirety of your trajectory past the
future
so that you can kind of see the dots in
the past
and the dots in your future trajectory
toward your north star
and kind of have that really help you
yeah that's a pretty high demand but
i'll do i'll do my best
i don't know i think no and i think
that's fair and i don't mean to like
make light of it because no i think it
is um
i think um the what the one thing i'll
relate on with that is
uh this thing i always think about
einstein i was thinking about
him like this summer again i came up
with in college and you know we're all
like philosophizing and talking about
how like you know there's colors going
on right now that we can't see with our
eyes and like
stuff so crazy um you know and staying
up and watching the sunrise but uh
one of my favorite thoughts from some of
those like conversations
um was just this idea of like einstein
wasn't a genius because he had all these
crazy thoughts
what made him a genius is him actually
being able to grab it and like
explain it to the rest of us like that's
kind of yes so i think um
yeah i think uh and
one in that way one it's funny and like
in that way
all my songs are in hindsight right
because me getting them
is like the present and then the
hindsight part is me like
unload you know like me mixing a song is
me like unloading what does this mean
right is me like you know looking at it
in past tense like that's what mixing is
is like putting all this
past tense like um unpacking
into a song and by the time it's
finished it's like
it's a whole other thing you know it's
like it's not even it's yeah it's
totally
in the past by the time it's finished
and i think a lot of people look at that
different they're like oh this brand new
song just happened
and it's like no no no that thing's like
probably two years old
the best meme to communicate what you're
talking about is the guy that
is walking he's walking up
stairs to get to the top of the stage
where there's this massive audience
watching him
and and he's a plate juggler and what
nobody sees is all the broken plates
on the staircase leading up so whenever
people deploy something like what you're
describing
i do my best to always look at
the creative process
for that deployment because when i when
i listen in the example of like
zeb's music i when i when i
when i'm listening to it i basically
begin kind of trying to unpack
what like the as an example like what
the ableton layers
look like and so for me that's sort of
my way of trying to go into the artist's
perspective of
how they piece this masterpiece together
and
and then yeah so let's maybe yeah let's
just check it so
just i guess to the listeners is just
pay you know
and it's probably hard through youtube
and you know it's probably not going to
be as fidelity as it's meant to be but
the idea here is that this is kind of a
more
modern sound that i'm that i'm exploring
with and that i'm pushing towards
okay so we're going to listen to uh and
watch
hate to say tease
yeah and this would be nice just to do
the preview
[Music]
we're just standing in the line
we're just standing here
man i love that oh cool man i'm glad i'm
glad
yeah and and you can kind of you know
it's funny like you can kind of
hopefully feel you know it's basically
me as the character
like we don't have everything in common
but he definitely
has um a a
heavy peppering of failure throughout
like all the things that happen
in in this story that's like that i'm
gonna drop like this full-length video
of
but um but yeah that that's my
best shot at kind of describing some of
the stuff i went through because it was
tough like i didn't know how to deal
i didn't have any tools yeah i didn't
know how to deal so like i had to figure
out kind of all on my own you know and
um but anyway so um i really i really
like that song in particular
um and i and i hope it shows like kind
of that example right it's like these
impossible strings like those aren't
even possible you know like it's
it's like there's some sampled stuff
there's stuff i layered on top of it and
that's the other piece that's crazy is
like
i'm using these sample libraries that
are recorded with the best mics
in million dollar rooms with the best
players on the planet wow and
so like all of a sudden you have access
to this like you know this whole other
universe um
how do you get access to that universe
um it's just you just end up
spending a lot of money on software you
know what is this like for people that
maybe yeah so yeah so yeah totally so
um contact has been like the standard
for a long time that's a native
instruments
like platform actually contact contact
yeah and so there's a bunch of libraries
that people make
for that platform um and you pay like a
subscription
some of them are so so on that one
actually that one's east west and that's
yeah that's very much like an able or um
adobe like subscription based kind of
thing so you you pay every month and you
have access to
this huge library of like on you know
again just impossible strings
that you can't you know like to pay to
like have an orchestra
show up and do what you're getting yeah
it's you know you're you're talking like
10
000 an hour you know minimum so um
so yeah it just yeah and it really just
pulls the lid off of like what you're
able to do and you know it's someone
that grew up
grew up like broke you know like it's
really nice all of a sudden to be like
wait a second
these tools aren't that expensive like
this is affordable now and i can like
and i'm not being limited by that
that feels really nice too like exactly
and i got democratization
and i and i have to say like there's
been
so much like negative vibes off of
people about
using the computer or using these kind
of softwares and stuff
and like i just want to take a moment to
like thank you
everyone that like makes this software
and does all this because it makes all
this possible
amen and it and it makes like it's a
huge gift and it's
changed my life like these people have
changed my life like in a fundamental
way yes where i can wake up every
morning and do
whatever i want yes and like just that
freedom
is like thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you you know like
yes you're speaking the same language
that we speak
here with sure exactly like oh my gosh
look at all the cameras look at all the
audio equipment look at all the
the the tricaster look at all the mixer
that we need to be grateful for totally
well and and okay you know and obviously
like there's a lot of stuff going on
right now and it's and we're in a tough
time but i think people
forget to like remember that like we're
in a run
like we're in an artistic renaissance
for sure
that like they're they're going to look
back on this period of time where it was
like
wait a second all of a sudden these
laptops got powerful enough
and it's j and it's still just kind of
happening like this is like maybe you
know maybe
2010 i think was like the first time i
was like
wait a second this computer is getting
strong enough where i can
kind of do this yes yes and i couldn't
afford what was like
available at that time but like now you
know now i have this
uh you know i have the desktop mac and
it's like
endless yeah and again in the software's
just kept getting better and better like
some of the software i'm going to show
you
um like you know this this update for um
this eq
pretty i think it's pretty recent i
think it was like within the last year
it's changed everything like it changes
how i approach everything
and it's just one plug-in you know and
yeah because i mean it's such a
fundamental thing and queueing is like
really fun but
just the way it works some of it's wiser
yeah equalization
equalization and are you going to kind
of also
break that down a little bit when you
show us kind of yeah i think that's the
main thing i'll probably go over is just
like i'll be like here's what this eq
looks like in in
you know like how we're approaching
fidelity right we're
trying to scope out everything you don't
use
so that everything you want to like all
the information you want present is as
clear
and as loud as you can possibly make it
because you know so we could in a sense
we could like use
eq to do something like take the ambient
noise of the
fireplace and turn that down 100 stuff
like that yeah yeah i get a little
like we could like pretty much get that
to be non-existent that's so interesting
and we can do that yeah
whoa and there's programs like there's
this program called rx
i think we're on like i don't know which
version i think i have rx6 but
you can literally sample something like
that noise and it will
erase it out of audio just sample it
right
yeah so you sample it without somebody
talking over it and then you talk over
and it actually does like it
it's kind of magic it's like magic yeah
it's like kind of a little bit of black
magic
they do it really well too is basically
take this exact
audio waveform and remove it from the
next audio and it's just
it's gone and then all of a sudden it
sounds like you were in like a perfect
booth
okay so let's see here so we covered the
democratization
and of the technology enabling creative
explosion i would also make a small
asterisk in that that you're our classic
people that kind of are
posting on maybe like twitter i think
that
that style of like 140 characters or 280
characters thinking that that's
something that people will scrape into i
think is a little bit
people still will and treat that kind of
like artistically
but i think more so people will care
about
like what zeb mentioned with the
like contact library exploding
and then that enabling and the
computational capacity enabling people
to put together
music or with this style of technology
it's all of the videos and all these
video conversations and taking the
samples out of there
so i guess i would just challenge in a
sense people to try and get a little bit
off of um instagram and twitter
and trying to make a cool artistic push
on that
it's it's okay you can do that but i'm
i'm just saying that i think the next
level is to try and take something um
like maybe a
like a like something that you pour a
lot of effort into on
on uh something like music production or
on video production
and try and make something that is a
really good sort of compression and
distillation of
of profound wisdom potentially that that
you've learned
i mean it is an art in a sense to try
and boil it down to a couple
characters but anyway on
on uh i wanna i wanna talk a bit
like you were kind of initially um
getting us a little bit
initialized into the process of talking
about eq and talking about these
yeah these other aspects um so just
quickly
hindsight was we had uh two
samples right and so far and that those
are
samples of what the full songs right so
those were those are like the
um promotion material i built for like
okay the song's out at midnight check it
out kind of thing
yes um and i've done one of those little
teasers for each
uh single that's come out so far yeah so
just it's just
like a very small snippet of the song
and then hindsight is
up uh approximately 20.
so so in this so this was kind of cool
um i
i basically gave myself a deadline of
whatever happens
this year um that's the album like
hindsight
einstein like it has like one i i need a
deadline
regardless but shot clocks are very
important yeah yeah to time box
something is like the only way i'm able
to get stuff done and i
and it's so funny i've been resisting
that forever like my sister has been
telling me for years she's like just
time box it and i'm like i don't know
how to do that like
i'm too creative or you know like i just
couldn't quite just be like no no
it's you know yeah it's this it's like
just hard hard
deadline um but what you know will
really help me with that too is like the
motivation of like
you know i know it's kind of stupid but
like the idea of hindsight
like it has to come out in 2020 like
just like that's the year it has to come
out because
because hindsight is you know like i
know i know it's sort of dumb but yeah
like
perfect so and then to further that kind
of like dumb
cuteness kind of like thing um
if yeah if i got 20 songs like that's
just another like boom that's kind of
fitting
but will i get that i don't know i still
don't know for sure yeah because it's
it's not like i can't sit back and be
like oh yeah the album's done
i'm still like right and it's really
interesting too because you know with
grandma's funeral for instance that i
was speaking about and um
you know there's some other things that
are pulling me back to colorado this
year i probably spent
six weeks in colorado so yeah i was
behind schedule and then now all of a
sudden it's like
you know what do i have a month and a
half left exactly so yeah so we'll see
and if i can do it great but you know
what
it's going to happen exactly the way
it's supposed to do and
bare minimum like count on at least 14
songs
easily so yeah beautiful so
that's uh we have we have hindsight and
we'll have that
uh probably whatever the first week by
first
week of 2021. no no the the album will
be
written like it has to come out like
december 31. there's no yeah there's no
way it's later than
year's day midnight yeah so december 31
you guys we got you guys got that
and then um we have
uh we have the work so far we have this
kind of working
uh nostalgia is kind of like your next
like 2021
yeah and then we have the uh
potentially next coast which is later so
you you kind of you're already
also slowly uh and these kind of have
different essences to them you were
telling me that
sure and true north has more of a
pointed and defining style
and more of like your anchor uh
creatively and then
hindsight is more moody um and then
nostalgia will have its own essence
and stuff like that yeah yeah so i can
speak on that a little bit so i'd say
again yeah true north was like okay just
remember how you got these songs right
like this is your
this is your flag on the moon like just
if you get lost come back here
um and so that was me really like
cutting my teeth like developing okay
this is kind of how the workflow is
going to be the sound of it is actually
like pretty 80s almost like it has this
like really throwback 80s kind of vibe
which um which is going to come back
like there'll be other songs that sound
like that but
that's probably the you know the most of
that sound you're gonna get in one album
is that album which
is the ep it's not the first like so why
i say
my first album's hindsight is because
it's the first full length
i would consider true north more like an
ep and again it is it's like a
it's like it was more of a testing
ground okay this is my entry point this
is how my process worked this is my
workflow
let's experiment with like how it works
solidify it great
and then i think hindsight is just a
continuation of like okay i really want
to explore this even more
and like push myself a little further so
it was even probably more complex than
true north
which true north was already way
overdone probably so this
so hindsight's like really very
complicated like lots and lots of stuff
like
crazy chords uh really fancy lyrics you
know like a lot of time on that but
the the biggest thing is just like the
instrumentation and the sound design and
just
you know like you were saying the layers
like each song is like 200 tracks
probably like it's insane
other than like maybe the intro that's
the the jazz song or here and there
you'll get some like low fidelity like
clips
and like little intros and outros and
stuff but the bulk of it is
super complicated um which is great um
and i think i've finally exhausted like
kind of
where i want to reach you know like all
the different things i wanted to explore
a little bit
and i think with nostalgia i'm very
excited to like kind of sit back
you know like maybe retreat a little bit
back into this like
core place of like i know this works
yeah and get a lot of work done in that
space where
well and i think it'll be nice too
because i think the goal for 2021
is speed like i'm re and that's why i'm
really hoping to get two
full-length albums done that year and
have one be a nostalgia which again
would be like the ultimate make out
album kind of the slow stuff
and then next coast which is just like
get your [ __ ] dancing shoes on like
we're going to show you guys
we're going to go ultimately right right
it's kind of interesting you and i are
finding ourselves in a similar
rhythm where i kind of had in 2018 and
2019
about 700 interviews an interview a day
and then i took 2020 to synthesize and
distill
high level perception and now with the
move to la it's right back into the
an interview a day type fire so
it's kind of interesting that like you
also had this
kind of uh anchor point like mine was
halo perception yours is true north
and now you have your sort of you
figured out a bunch of kind of your core
music production essence kind of like i
figured out a bunch of my core cognitive
frameworks
and now it's just like create create
create from
that place yeah i love that no it's
really exciting and it's super
liberating
um and i'm sure there's going to be a
time where i'm like okay now i want to
break all this apart and kind of start
over but
i'm excited for you know at least the
next few years to just
just yeah just kind of you know reap the
benefit of like all this work i've done
all this like groundwork i've done and
just see
how many songs i can get done and like
how good i can make them yes
you know so yeah it's it's and it feels
really nice too to like feel like the
bulk of the work is
over and now now i'm just yeah oh god
it's so
good weight off my shoulders so good so
crazy you need that
talk like you were talking about that
time boxing you said your sister was
trying to
well yeah so they're all software people
so like they're all minimal viable
products like get the song front to back
first boom and i've adopted that like so
i write so sometimes i will write an
entire song without even touching an
instrument it's all the lyrics the
melody like it makes sense front to back
i could play it for someone they're like
oh that's a song yep
right and maybe i'll do the instruments
even just with my voice just to get it
done
like just memorable product and then go
from there and that was huge
and then yeah time boxing it's huge
exactly huge it's super interesting you
make the analogy to tech and software
engineering well
it's so hand in hand it is well that's
the other thing like there's no rock
stars anymore i think that are like
i mean i'm sure there still are but like
the people that i respect the most
they're actually we're actually like
more like computer nerds than we are
like
yeah motley crue like it's not that it
you know it's not that crazy lifestyle
anymore now it's like
okay well maybe if i um you know eat
more potassium and get to bed better on
time then i'll really be able to
maximize my you know
oh it's insane and i get it well this is
another thing i had to adopt like i
still have to get loose
like when i'm writing the songs a lot of
times i still have to really get loose
but then
when it comes to like finishing and
polishing it to the level i want to and
doing the technical
stuff i really do switch like it's
putting a whole different hat on yeah
totally so yeah it's kind of
yeah the hyper uh creative strategic and
then the other one is kind of like hyper
operational and executional
yeah because it's work it's and that's
the thing it's not you know it's not all
like glamorous it's like
it's computer nerd working it's computer
nerd work yeah
i i like that the the time boxing
mvp and shot clock in like basketball or
like red zone and football and now is
that a good feeling when you sink a
three-pointer and just
god it just comes off the fingertips
like three
two one yeah there's there's
exactly it's gotta happen and um and
you gotta remember that you're gonna
take the 10 thousand shots
and right now right yeah so you're gonna
miss some and you know wayne gretzky
also
talks about that um the best hockey
players has ever lived and
like you you you're gonna miss a hundred
percent of shots you don't take so
you have to take the ten thousand yeah
and that you're going to miss a lot of
those yeah
well and i think when i think that's why
like working really hard and
quickly is so effective it's because
like it gets you through
all that you just shlog through all that
so it's all this trial and error you
know it's like
again trying to find that entry point
yes and you're like
you know you're like in a maze bumping
around the walls blindfolded like and
you just
you just run really fast and not not be
afraid of hitting the walls and like
falling over and getting back up
but if you go hard and fast like you're
gonna get through the maze quicker than
someone just like you're
you're describing also what um the
the reinforcement learning agents do in
their
uh simulated environments which is super
interesting what is it
they also like reinforcement learning
agents when they enter into their
simulated environments what they do is
they kind of go through this process of
basically
like trying to understand what
the world that they immerse themselves
into and like
what the reward function is and how they
can kind of do different items in the
space so
like if you're if you're trying to like
do something like a game of sumo or
whatever like that they also like slowly
over time the agents will figure out
that they can like
kind of like push each other out of the
ring okay and then
earn the points okay and then but they
kind of they flail around a lot
well just take me one step back though
so who are these agents
it would be like it would be like what
when what did you call them again
reinforcement learning reinforcement
agents yeah so reinforcement learning is
arguably
the most profound um branch of
artificial intelligence and machines oh
okay okay okay
one of them i mean self-play is probably
the most profound branch but
um yeah so like the the idea is like
you're describing when you're when you
blindfold and then you
courageously bump into the walls and the
maze and if you fall over you get back
up
the reinforcement learning agents in
these simulated environments
they do that style process where they
like fall
like it's all trial and error all
learning to become peak performance
and so the more that you kind of realize
that that is what
these individual conscious agents are
is is that process the more kind of
fearless and courageous you are to
pursue that
that north star and those goals when i
think and that's the thing that's
interesting too is i think people
sorry just really quick because i just
want to i want to say this to like
you know eight-year-old me or whatever
and i want to say to anyone that's
trying to do
music or anything creative i think
sometimes people get confused by
watching someone that's already there
being like look well they're not working
that hard and it's like dude but they
found that
that's because they've already front
loaded all the work so so they like
watch this person and they're like oh
well i just want to be like that where
it's like super easy and i just show up
and i sing
and i do the fun part and i never have
to do any of the hearts i'll give the
most common example used
today which is um people look at joe
rogan and they're like uh
like 10 million subs and he just walks
in and has a conversation
but they don't go and look at the 11
years of 1500 plus
podcast conversations where in like the
first hundred
it's them screwing around with the
streaming technology to try and make it
actually
happen so that's kind of like
it's again it's the plate juggler the
steps of the plate juggler
before they get on stage so if like you
described with your foundation that you
set up
that's now enabling you to produce the
two albums in 2021 yeah
hopefully one again that's the goal but
so back to my eight-year-old self just
like
look buddy like i was never afraid of
the hard work and i did do the hard work
but don't
doubt that that's the right thing
because sometimes i would doubt i would
see these
people seemingly doing it effortlessly
and i'd be like i must be doing
something wrong
and no and i promise you you're not you
just have to get through all the trial
and error
until you find the way that you can do
it effortlessly yeah yeah but
so much of that is just just go as hard
as you can
until you crack the code and you can
literally deliver something
easily that's the whole goal is to get
to where it is easy but
getting there it's not you're not the
only way to get there is by to do all
the hard stuff
and you have to be in love at least of
doing the hard stuff
and yeah i would i would just also
balance the mentality of
what sort of the gary vaynerchuk
mentality of you gotta go through the
the hard work of of 10 years of eating
[ __ ] in a sense and trying to put
everything together
yeah and with the kind of peter thiel
mentality of
why can't you do what you're going to do
in the next 10 years why can't you
achieve that in six months
and so i would synthesize those two
perspectives
and so try your best to like for example
i'm just going to give you an example
with me
i could have instead of doing a show a
day 700 shows in two years in 2018 2019
i could have done a show a week and i
could have only done 100 shows
in those two years but i would have went
through a lot less trial and error a lot
less combinations of this type of stuff
so i would say that um you can
sort of quote shortcut and quote
accelerate yourself and your goals
by realizing that
there are strategic ways to move
yourself towards your goals faster at
the same time as you do
in fact have to just eat a lot of poop
along the way yeah oh yeah dude
huge [ __ ] sandwich like you just gotta
but like that's the thing it's and again
and again like just just i don't wanna
get the biggest thing i'd want to say is
i think a lot of people do feel like
they're working really hard just
just just don't doubt because it's hard
enough to fall in your ass all the time
and to do the trial and error
so in that period of time just try not
to question
am i doing the right thing just know
that you are trust the process
and let yourself get beat up and like be
courageous with it and like
don't take a lot of time to beat
yourself like beating yourself up was
probably the biggest time sink of my
life
for sure and it was really hard for me
because again i struggled with
depression and like my past
definitely exacerbated all that my um
you know my experience with school and
my learning disabilities and
some of the teachers i had to deal with
in high school like exacerbated all that
i mean i got some stories dude like what
are you gonna start my my band director
in high school yeah
unbelievable like ugh it was just it was
atrocious like it's emba
i was like man i would be so embarrassed
if i was you like how
like why would you treat kids like that
it's just bananas but anyway so
yeah and the idea that one
can uh kind of not dwell
so much in those uh traumas but rather
like integrate them really well
integrate your shadow really well and
use that as the fire
one talk about easier said than done
like i know you know like
and i struggle with it so much because
you know like okay i'll give one example
so there was a high school recital
or sorry the senior recital in high
school for
band right so jazz band and um the
marching band and all that stuff so
and each senior that night had a solo
except for me and i had i have no idea
it was a total surprise and i felt yeah
it was so effed up like literally
i'm sitting there and he starts to
introduce all the seniors and he's like
this senior's gonna give their solo and
all of this was planned and had been
going on for months
and nobody talked to you about it well i
just had no idea like i had no idea to
talk like i don't think and i don't
think that i think all the students
just assumed that everything right so
they had no reason to be like yo
zeb like do you have i think you know i
think
you know i think homeboy is like pulling
a fast one on you
so i had no warning and then the
concert's over and i'm just like
wow you were and it's crazy too because
i
raised like 15 000
in grant money and put a recording
studio in his facility
wow yeah and he kept being like you got
to teach me how to use this stuff and i
was like anytime man just like call me i
gave him my numbers like set up a time
like i'd love to
never followed through just i don't know
he just hated me like it was just the
weird he's just like
i don't know it's the most bizarre thing
but i'll never forget that night i stand
up out of the chair
after like you know playing as well as i
could like you know
practicing a lot like it was a huge
concert whatever and being the only
senior that
wasn't mentioned didn't get a solo and i
was the kid going to berkeley
that was the other part i was like what
is this like okay like whatever
so anyway getting over that let's see
you get to i'm still not over
like you know like but that's the piece
it's like uh sometimes this thing
happened and it's like
but you just gotta whatever like you
just gotta know that like
those people who knows what that thing
is but
you can't doubt you can't use those
things to let like you can't let those
people
have any kind of power because that's
the other part until you like forgive
that situation
it's still me giving him power to like
you know further that abuse
or whatever that thing he was doing to
me was anyway
side tangent but wow don't doubt
yourself don't let people crush your
dreams
like don't take that stuff personally it
has nothing to do with you yeah
eight-year-old self thanks for thanks
for sharing that story we all have so
many
likes it's important to hear
people talking about that courageously
and
how they've moved on and integrated it
becomes stronger wiser sure do
do we want to uh hit
um it seems like maybe we should do
music breakdown
and then yeah music stuff right because
the future music stuff's a little bit
more like
in the next like the 10 years like
autonomous car those type of stuff
yeah well i mean either way i mean
because i think one addresses the other
i think actually you know what i
wouldn't mind talking about
like why yeah actually talking about the
future of music i think will give the
listeners maybe a chance to be like
why do i want to look at eq right so
maybe you know what i mean like it'll be
you know what i mean like it'll kind of
be like this is why i'm even showing you
this is because
let's do that yeah so what i want to i
guess how i would want to maybe start
this
future of music section out with is
something along the lines of
a couple days ago
zeb is telling me on the phone
a lot of people that are very familiar
with the
exponential technology curve and just
the proliferation of
autonomous vehicles people
are becoming more aware of this thanks
to people like andrew yang who were
trying to get more people awake to the
fact that
the all the jobs in the uh
the the taxi cab driving space coming as
well as the truck driving space
are millions in the us and tens of
millions globally
are being automated and we'll see that
more and more
you know by 2030 and and whatnot and so
um what zeb is interestingly coming
at at the angle with is
he's saying that um telling me
on on the phone so fascinating that
what's what's gonna happen is that
people are going to care
less and less about things like the most
massive
engine inside of the car and they're
going to care more about the comfortable
the comfortability of the seats they're
going to care more about this
the quality of the speaker system can
you put an ambisonic system inside of a
car
they're going to care about the the
quality of the screens and
things like that and and that zebs he
goes a step further and he's like
you know you're in the autonomous car
like most people
spend like if we think about it as a
planet if there's eight billion people
and if maybe
i don't know a couple billion of them
drive every day i don't know a couple
billion let's say
drive every day how many
hours are people spending on
being stressed they're just white
knuckling yeah just like knuckling
hating
just and just cars and the rage and the
frustration and
like and this is my life just passing me
by and i'm stuck in this yeah
and and yeah in transitioning that our
commute or whatever
it's going to be straight up global
relief through a massive
planetary focus on
decreasing stress lower cortisol levels
like in chapter six in the ai coach
section we talk a lot about
the visualization of data right above
all else show the data edward tufte and
so if you could see the planetary
cortisol levels literally drop
once you have the autonomous vehicles so
zeb's probably going to end up being
one of i think the pioneers in the
space of enabling um
people in the immersive experiences
where they don't have to work for the
hour or however long they're in the
vehicle
that they can focus on this deeply
profoundly enriching
musical experience immersive experience
um
and so i think also what you'll see in
when zeb as he was alluding to earlier
what you'll see when he does the demo
is you'll see this uh all of the
layers all the tracks you you can hear
them
best when you're in the sort of more
ambisonic style
setting with higher quality speakers
that are around your dolby surround
sound style
rather than um when you're maybe where
like when you're wearing your little
well it's not even is it so i'll just
i'll jump in so yeah yeah so it's not
even like here at best
it's so many of the devices that we use
to deliver music
they're not providing half of the
information that so many of us are like
you know painstakingly put together um
yeah and so unless you have a really
decent pair of headphones um and then
again
with this card uh you know autonomous
car situation where
you're actually going to be quick
question is that is that actually the
percent is
we we hypothesize that it's not even
delivering 50
of the data okay that might be an
exaggeration i mean it's
well it's hard to say there's there's a
bunch of different limitations right
like it's like we were talking about
like air is not necessarily the best
conductor of sound to begin with
our ears are super limited right so
there's limitations on on
a few different fronts um
but yeah i would say
until you're in a situation where
your speakers or headphones are
giving you a full spectrum you know
range of what your
ears can hear low and high because our
ears can only hear so low
and so high but um once you have a
delivery system that's at least giving
you that
you're yeah you're missing a lot of
information and then two
you know i think a really you know like
a almost way more substantial part of it
is your attention span right like if
you're not paying attention it doesn't
matter anyway
so i think that's another part of what's
so exciting about like the autonomous
car
piece um at least again just at least
from
an entertainment standpoint like like
you were bringing up earlier
um you know with the the loss of jobs
that's going to happen and
how it could impact the economy and um
you know cause those problems i
i can't speak on that at all and like i
don't know how that's gonna play out and
i hope it's not this disastrous thing or
whatever but
how it will affect someone's experience
with music i think does have potential
to be
one of the upsides right so so i think
this thing's coming
either way um i'm not like i don't want
to say like i'm a big proponent of all
these people losing their job i want to
make that clear
but i think that it's it's kind of the
there's going to be
like with anything else there's going to
be positive effects and negative effects
and
maybe one of the silver linings let's
say would be this
you're now a captive audience now you're
bored now instead of being stressed out
you're about to fall asleep like and i
can imagine a lot of people just
you know that's their extra hour they
get to sleep on their commute to work
you know
they're just passed out the whole time
but um if you are awake
you'll be literally in a situation where
you have nothing else to do but to
like really actually let yourself hear
the music um
so there's a couple of things there's
them you really hear the music
really immerse yourself in the podcast
maybe really
entertainment in the work also work for
you yeah any yeah anything you want to
do but i think
that's that's the part that's exciting
me or again hopefully could be a silver
lining for some of the negative impacts
that it
is probably going to cause um but yeah
and when i like the idea too that like
someone could just be meditating the
whole time to work
and like just really you know focusing
on their their mental health or whatever
um
because i think yeah i think that's one
of the things that's really holding us
back is mental health you know like
we're still blowing each other up and
doing war like we still engage in all
these terrible institutions and i think
a lot of that is because of
you know people being in desperation and
people having you know
having you know having yeah having you
know being really twisted up inside
about stuff and
um and again there's tons of different
reasons for that but hopefully this for
some people
could you know be something really
beneficial but the the whole point i
think we even started that conversation
on the phone
um at least from from my standpoint was
i was just trying to
describe to you why that's kind of
important because i've always wanted to
make something with stands the tested
time right like that was always really
important like when i
would listen to the beatles i was like
there's some there's some there's
something about this
is genesecular there's this uneffable
thing that
makes it still work now you know louis
armstrong same thing like
he codified jazz in this way that it's
just like you can always go back and it
just works it's like
it's still applicable um and i would
love for my music to do that
um not only with you know lyrics and all
the traditional stuff like
good chords good arrangement like all
that but now there's this whole other
layer
that's just as artistic which is okay so
this reverb is going to kind of come in
here and then go that way and then you
know
you're you're really it's like you're
not only if you arrange the music
but then you're getting all these weird
sounds to like
you know be able to spin around and do
backflips and like hear things behind
your head like
i've literally and again i'm not even
like there's people that
especially sound design wise that just
are slay like one of my really good
friends anthony baldino for instance he
can make something sound like it's
happening behind your head
in in just in stereo like not not not
because you're in surround sound
you know he does yeah like super super
high technical
like just yeah he and all the tools he's
and he's
you know i mean to talk about putting in
time like kids
well yeah justin just with two speakers
being able to make something literally
feel like
you're like what the yeah um would be
cool anthony it would be cool
anthony baldino would be cool to also
bring on hey if you can
if you can get him if you can get him
man yeah like he's you can connect
yeah if you can afford it you can no but
no i mean
he's just so busy like getting his time
is like come and teach
the wisdoms that you know yeah i mean if
he if i think he i mean yeah
it's it's maybe interesting it would no
no he would if you could get him
he's fascinating like he's he's a really
cool guy he's
yeah again he his knowledge base is nuts
but anyway so
um yeah there's certainly people that
that's all they do right is they spend
all their time
on the sound design part and you know
they definitely will wipe them i think
but i think
my strength is that i can i can make
this song that's catchy and i can
do the chords right and i can play the
instruments and
i'm starting to like really push my edge
with
where the production stuff's going to
happen and how i can kind of compete
with those guys because i do i think
as people are paying more and more
attention they're going to be noticing
it more and more so
in time without that you know it has a
it has a
it has a higher probability that it's
going to kind of go out of style because
it's like
it's not holding up anymore because all
this music's so so technically
um dope sound wise just sound wise you
know like
you could have a very simple song that
everyone can sing along to but just the
way it sounds is so
next level that that could i mean that
that's becoming its own like
form of a hook you know like having a
really you know
juicy uh awesome course you can sing
along to that's that's a hook
but having it sound so crazy that's
really another way of just like grabbing
someone being like listen to this
you know and that's what we're realizing
more and more is like this technology is
opening this kind of other dimension of
how to grab people's attention yes so
yeah i love that
whoo so pumped gosh no it's exciting
renaissance man we are in a renaissance
i'm telling you and it's j
and it's still really young like some of
this techno like again this
eq is like changing everything i do
let's do it okay so
really fast and i know this is you know
this is probably a little nerdy or
whatever
um and i'll try not to like i don't want
this to be like
nerdy on the program we like the doses
of nerdy
you came to the right place hold on give
me one second
don't switch it over yet all right give
me a few
there we go let me just make sure of
course because it kind of gets sleepy
sometimes let's make sure it's not too
sleepy okay cool
okay you're ready when you watch all
right so we're switching it over for you
guys
cool so and again not to have this turn
into like an ableton
tutorial there's plenty of those online
oh that's kind of cool instead of our
logo right now above your head
it's your um the thumbnail oh there you
go yeah i like
that yeah that's taking over i'm taking
it he took over the show
okay so just so really quickly this
isn't
this isn't anything crazy like this is a
normal eq this is this is pretty
standard um most eqs have always been
some version of this um once the
computer stuff started to happen like
once it's not knobs on a
console this is this isn't that crazy it
looks way better it's way cooler to look
at
but basically what we're looking at
dynamically adjusts
on digitally for you to see rather than
the knobs
right which is really really powerful
for instance you know um
for instance i can grab one of these
peaks i'd be like obviously that's
feeling high
and i can duck oop hold on hold on oh
we're fine
ah sorry okay i switched back
don't look at my my private information
no okay so okay
sorry back to it so here we are um
we're taking that peak we're actually
able to push down on it so we're pushing
against it
um and again none of this is too crazy
but
what has started to happen that's
getting really nuts
is we're able to and this is going to be
a little tricky to
explain but side chain these specific
areas so i could actually take this
right i can make it dynamic so it's
going to push
against just this area in the song
and let's say this is this is the entire
track this is everything but
maybe the voice right so we're gonna
take
every time i'm singing and i start to
get a little louder in my voice
this is gonna push just this area
of the track of everything other than
the voice down
so it's so instead of boosting my vocal
up
i'm pushing everything else down and i'm
doing that in a specific area
okay instead of because you know and
side chaining's been around for a long
time too right this is called side chain
side chaining yeah so it's it's a way of
turning something else down so you don't
have to turn up the vocal basically and
that's usually that's that's a big way
it gets used
or like kick drums you side chain kick
drums a lot so is this is this one you
kind of like are maybe watching um a
video and there's like a
there's a transition that occurs
where the kind of like the like the
videos
music track is playing and then
the human's voice comes in and they bump
down the music track a little bit so the
human's voice can be
exactly so exactly you're ducking you're
ducking one volume for another because
this is the deal it's like so
so like um so like this
cup of water right okay you can fill it
all the way up but that's it
once once you keep pouring water on it's
just gonna overflow and that's what
distortion is you can
turn like so if you turn up everything
super loud it's just going to distort so
at some point
you have a limit you only have this
amount of space to fill now what's now
my question would be what's the
difference
between you know how when you use one of
the functions
on um whether it's music production
software or whether it's even on like
video editing software
where you basically take the the tracks
dbs and you drop them in that specific
section yes where you the vocal human
vocal comes up
right so what's the difference between
is that eq what is the difference
between that and this
okay so so what you're speaking about is
like basically doing it manually like
you could go in and literally
do that by hand yes um you can do it
with a compressor
this is allowing you to do it in a very
specific
space because it's allowing an eq it's
allowing an equalizer to duck so not i'm
not ducking the whole track
i'm ducking one part of the frequency
range right so i'm taking i'm saying
this i want 400 hertz i want that to go
away when the voice comes in
right i want interesting so the rest of
the music track
is placed at the same volume except at
400. so
now yes so now you're getting so um
uh surgical surgical it's just crazy and
this and
there's one other step on top of that
that i was just starting to mess with
literally earlier this week i was like
wait a second there's oh and
we're cutting out we're we're ducking
something down in a very specific area
to allow space for something else so we
don't overflow our cup
yep right and the next layer on top of
that
um eqs and again this isn't new but
eqs have always had functions for mid
and side
so mid information is everything that
both speakers are doing oh okay and then
side information is if
one you know your right speaker is kind
of doing a certain thing and your left
speaker is doing a certain
and that's a really nice thing to play
with especially with vocals for instance
so you can get a little bit of
um you know just widens it up because it
sounds a little bit different on this
speaker than this speaker
so it gives you this like stereo field
and a lot of times
my vocals are layered i'll have two of
me singing or three
well a lot of times it's like four or
five of me there's this song by
maji jordan where it kind of goes like
okay and you know it
and it was amazing yeah yeah your
demonstration was super on point
and that's like what people love yeah
yeah panning yeah
you will messing around with people's
expectations right something surprising
again
okay so you pay attention to this the
audio engineering on both the left
and the right at specific frequencies
okay so the way i would explain it is
this yes so let's say
i took are we back yeah so i took this
thing i want it to duck
out just this frequency when the vocal
is coming
in and then i only want that to happen
to the side information
okay and then it's just bananas okay and
so so i'm gonna do
like so with my vocals for instance i
would have
like if this was a vocal side chain
setup i would have probably
probably less of a this is a pretty well
no that's 58 that's probably fine
i might have something that looks like
this like they were in all of these
would be
dynamic and they would all be specific
to like so the mids
i'd want more mid-range i'd want more
center feeling
information of my lower voice to come
right
right in between your eyes right like
that that like provides a lot of
presence something in the middle like
your kick drums your voice you kind of
want it to really you want to really
feel it
coming oops coming through the middle
and then you kind of are playing with
people
to get this bigger feeling but you want
the potency boom so
i'm gonna punch you right down the
middle with the lower part of my voice
okay and i'm gonna make the track duck
right so that that can happen right
so i'm going to knock out um or actually
this would be the opposite sorry
this little comp kid but i'm going to
take the side information out of that
area
so when my voice starts happening it's
getting rid of
or no sorry no i would keep that mid my
bad my bad i'm getting ahead of myself
i punched the mid out of the track so
more of the mid of the vocal comes
through
so i'm going to so i'm going to diminish
it here and then let it come through
um for that portion and then something
like with these
like with this area probably somewhere
in like a thousand maybe
this is kind of like that telephony
sound of your voice like where it
you know the the thousand hertz is kind
of where it's like it like if you just
had
the thousand hurt area boosted a lot it
would sound like you were on an old
crappy kind of telephone it's that like
it's like
it's like that pretty cutting part of
the voice um i might drop
some of that out of the stereo field
yeah and try to get that in the middle a
little bit too
and then maybe i would push so i could
get more
of the high information way up here i'd
want more of that maybe in the stereo so
the little sprinkly
high stuff that's catching your ear over
here
yeah and the more clear parts of the
voice are going right down the middle
and and it's all playing against the
music it's warping
so everything's mushing together mixing
together yeah you know
mixing wow and it's and it's really
helping us maximize
that full full full cup without having
to spill over and distort
interesting so this is usually what so
so p
audio engineers that focus on mixing are
really specialists in eq
oh yeah well well the whole thing so
reverbs you get any
any plug-ins um tons there's tons of
techniques but yeah
and and that's the thing that's a little
bit tricky is like yeah now we can do
all this stuff but we're still competing
with guys
that only mix him and only mix their
entire life that i will never be able to
touch same thing i was saying about
anthony baldino yeah i will never be
able to catch up with that guy in terms
of yeah i mean i
wouldn't i wouldn't want to like man
yeah it's so crazy so in a sense you're
doing
more of a you're doing like a vertical
stack of artist artistic capacity
whereas uh someone else like maybe
anthony has has kind of
monopolized a horizontal space of being
able to do that
well well him specifically he does a lot
of stuff he did as well oh no
he's a great composer he's music some
people do just yeah yeah yeah right
right yeah totally i mean
i don't want to go the full stack for
your abilities
right so i think my our and again my
entry point
into all this demands that i can do all
this myself for sure
so right so likewise right yeah yeah so
so in other people their entry point
they don't need all the other stuff like
you know i just want to mix or even
mastering engineers are even that's even
another crazy breed of people like
they take after the mix is done they
just take the stereo bounce so you have
all these tracks
you bounce it down to just a song file
what's on the right speaker what's on
the left speaker that's it they take
that file
just just that amount of information and
they do a whole other process on top of
it to make it even sound better
and that those people go nuts so they're
the ones that have like you know they'll
have these concrete pillars going 50
feet into the ground that is completely
isolated from the rest of the
facility and those are their speaker
stands like
yeah nuts like like like milli like
multiple million dollar
like spaces just to get the every little
last thing perfect
so yeah i love going into this level of
nerd because
i think it gives a more um nuanced uh
engineering perspective because it's
usually
when you just plug in them the
headphones and click play
on your um spotify or youtube song um
usually you're not
um diving into it's important to know
these
to know these depths now we actually
wanted uh to play
it's yours do we want to show anything
with the first minute of
it's yours or just play it i mean yeah
so basically
this this could show you a little bit of
um like this is just a good example
again of um and the one
so yeah i'll preface this song a little
bit so one it was really cool
um i was at my mother's house um
in arizona she'd recently moved arizona
i was out visiting her i had this laptop
um you know it was like the day was over
i was messing around trying to get a
song
and i didn't have a microphone with me
whatever so i'm singing into this laptop
and it was really interesting because
obviously
terrible microphone right capturing not
of quality audio
oh yeah and so this whole intro was all
recorded on a laptop microphone
and actually a through sound in the song
is is also that but i've put it through
a vocoder
i did all this stuff so namely even with
really low fidelity recordings now i
took all of my
tools and kind of challenged myself to
be like okay how can i but can i make
this
sound of fidelity even though it was
recorded on a freaking
you know like i don't know 2011 laptop
microphone
you know that's probably been damaged
right like it sounded like garbage and
um
interesting so that was a challenge for
you to do yeah well well i really liked
what happened
and i was like i'm not going to be able
to recreate this with my good microphone
at home
and besides like that moment's not now
now is now i want it like what can i do
and i
and again i was on that like minimal
viable product i was like no i want to
get to the end of this song i don't want
to wait until i'm in front of my better
equipment
yes so i showed up back at home with a
finished song
and going through the process and this
one was hard i got to say like this one
stumped me
i spent more time and it's still not
finished to be honest but
this makes yeah it was it was like a
task but
you know i learned a lot and i'll be
able to like take those skills with me
and it came out super creative and it's
something yeah you know
there's no other way i could have gotten
to something it sounded like this you
did it this way
right so like yeah so that was kind of a
fun part of it too
but but yeah this is this is an example
of using
all those techniques and yeah seriously
going hard on the eq to get something to
sound
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
boom wow yeah so that was super fun
and so in that drop you were mentioning
right that there's uh
yeah so like that kind of that that i
mean basically it's it's taking the
space of like a
synth lead line right it's actually my
voice just through all these processes
and that was another cool thing too is
it forced me to learn a lot of
um plug-ins i hadn't used yet because i
don't you know i don't have a lot of my
high-powered plug-ins on this laptop i
can't run them so
i downloaded all the ableton like the
free ableton plug-ins like all the
add-on kind of stuff and they have a you
know this kind of vocoder that does what
it does i mean it's not of
you know it's again it's not like it's
super
heavy hitter like big plug-in but it
does what it does
in a really interesting way and i just
was utilizing that and like i just
started
stacking up all these um these plug-ins
that
were really lightweight and you know i
had on the road with me
and then i came up with that and then
obviously when i got to the bigger rig
i was able to like massage it more with
some better plug-ins but
but again i would have never like like i
would have never come up with that
melody too that's the other thing that's
really fun is like i never would
have played that you know like i never
would have come up with that that's in
in that
you know in that timing like a suit it's
like super kind of off time it's super
weird
but then it's but it's like it's you
know like it's the wabi-sabi
it's that it's the secret sauce that's
this is a spicy sauce
yeah because if when when you go too
hard
into the perfection territory um you
actually
uh in a sense you miss out on the
creativity of the imperfection
which is super interesting well and
that's been and i think that's been
yeah that's been like a very poignant
theme of
artists lives yeah well it's been a
really interesting challenge or like
thing for me to cope with is like this
getting super loose and creative and
doing something like that but then
having to like
again put on the whole other hat and i
think in the past
a lot of musicians just got to be like
super crazy all the time and then the
engineers and the mixers
like were the ones that were like okay
the nerd the new nerd crew is going to
show up
you guys come come you know like make
this insane mess of creative fun stuff
and then
we'll do all the hard work of like that
and i mean of course it'd be awesome if
i like
could just be like oh yeah here's here's
a hundred thousand like you know i'm
gonna pay for the production of a justin
bieber song
and just show up and sing but i don't
know i kind of
i kind of liked the fact that that was
never an option for me and now i have to
do it this way
what what happened is now you have what
what i would say is like
the you have the vertical uh
as is said like 10 000 hours of mastery
sure
and because you now have that this acts
as your
foundation which then moving forward
it's like
everything you touch in the future every
person that you work with in the future
is going to know that you've been in
their
shoes doing that specific style that's
really important for the process well it
would be fun like
if and when i get to that space like i
will at least know to communicate really
well
and like collaborate with those people
hopefully um but i don't know if i'll
ever need to i mean i think
like someone like skrillex has seemed to
be able to just kind of leap through
that whole process like he does
everything himself and he's i mean he's
probably like the jimmy hendrix of the
computer
i mean at least that i know like that
that we know of yeah he's such a
shredder like
such a shredder when you go back and
listen to that stuff it's just like yeah
and there's so many people like that but
i think he really separated himself with
just how good the actual music part was
too like how fun it was to listen to how
catchy it was how like
digestible it was as like kind of pop
music really like it kind of would you
say like avicii's also oh absolutely
absolutely but i would interested yeah
and he was he was pretty sure
he was pretty shreddy but i think there
was something about that like
insane edm like all those crazy drops
and all those crazy sounds
just like the complexity there um and it
will and maybe i should yeah and i'm
sure like
i can imagine the comments people being
like well you didn't you haven't you
clearly haven't heard of this guy or
whatever so
and i'm not like an expert in that space
of music anyway but um
definitely gotta give mad props to um
screw legs oh and and
and no shade on justin bieber by the way
i know that that works super hard and
like i'm not saying likewise i'm not
saying oh he just like shows up
like i know he has his you know all the
stuff he has to deal with and he can
dance and he can do
you know he's he has a whole other set
of things it's always funny watching
um people because i i was also in the
same shoes maybe like
five plus years ago where i was kind of
like very
um just like creating some sort of like
a judgment about
someone and when you really have to take
your time to deeply immerse yourself in
their entire
trajectory like their whole roots their
essence and their fruits
in order for you to even grasp a tiny
taste
so it's it's very hubristic to try and
make some sort of a claim about
somebody's yeah well absolutely one i
think and i think like back to the entry
point thing it's like what a
bizarre thing to diss someone on like oh
your entry point into like making you
feel connected on this planet
um is dumb you know like what is that
like justin bieber
clearly found his entry point that's
right and he's killing it like
like for for sure and mine just happens
to be different so when when i brought
up his name it's just it was literally
just an example and it's more about
inspiring people to find their entry
points of unity of course exactly
yeah and do it however do whatever works
i think you know like
you know like with singing it's really
interesting it's like your best voice
is the you know well most people
describe your best voice
as whatever comes most naturally to your
body like
like most vocal coaches that's what
they're going to lead you down the path
of
is again trial and error figuring out
what feels the best
and like what's the easiest to you know
not strain yourself that generally is
what sounds the best too
yeah like nine times out of ten for me
it's something like this
and it's not that stressful oh my god
and it makes me feel so
great you're making me fall in love
you're hilarious girl i love you
i do you're so good like you're so good
on all these different levels and
it's so fun and i love how excited you
get like it's so fun just like
be around you because you're just like
yeah okay then we're going to do this
and we're doing the thing
here we go and move in now we're gonna
talk about consciousness
yeah it's funny we can do it all that's
the thing we can do it all and there's
no
there's never any like worry about oh my
gosh how am i gonna be perceived because
i did this boo
yeah now one of you take yourself too
seriously and like you can't just
have fun it's like i just feel i'm like
ah you poor thing like that sucks like
that must be
enough to be all like wound up that
tight like you know again that's
their entry point maybe their entry
point is to be like the most rigid
person everywhere but i don't know
that's been far and few between that
like super rigid people that aren't
happy
they don't feel like i feel like maybe
they're they're still getting there on
the entry point part but anyway
yeah yeah it's kind of almost an
indicator that they're not quite
well that's the only thing we can get
yeah 100 like no
and again and the the nutrients for the
seed to get to the entry point we need
to help on that
kind of sustainable development goal
level basic needs like water no poverty
or a hunger thing no totally one
and again the last thing i'll say on
that is just yeah some people that
you know maybe deserve love the least
need it the most so like be nice to
people even if they're kind of mean to
you like give
just give them an extra benefit of that
like go that extra thing to be like okay
they're being a dick i'm going to take a
breath
and instead of lashing back out then i'm
just going to be like all right man like
my bad and then see what happens yes
like see see like what like nine times
out of ten they're gonna be like oh my
bad like no that was just
and then that's like a good wholesome
moment for both of you
you know and like if it doesn't cost
anything if i may
even go as far as on your complete pull
of that
would be you know trying to channel
christ consciousness buddha
consciousness loud subconsciousness
confucius level consciousness
highest morality highest ethics highest
spirituality
highest butterfly effect of the most
possible benevolent
beingness at every moment of your life
on the
highest pole and if that kind of is part
of the
if that is part of the north star along
with your unique artistic gift
game over you are going to win at
everything period
so man i just realized what i probably
sounded like trying to describe the eq
that was that wasn't mouthful man that
was cool though
yeah i can't wait to talk to you more
like we have so much to talk to you
yeah i know we had to create on oh for
sure oh yeah yeah
yeah well and again like i think um just
i'm sure that people that you kind of
like manifested in your life or like
have around
i'm i'm like totally curious to meet all
of them and i'm sure they're like
it's going to be yeah worthwhile yeah
there's again like it's so interesting
because some
sometimes peop like people um
like use the word like synchronicity
or they um they sometimes fall into
nihilism where none of it is synchronous
and none of it has
meaning but to me there even the word
synchronicity itself i think everything
has a meaning and
everything has a purpose and it's all
beautiful and it's all
true and in a sense in this case where
it's like why is zebulon kroll the the
second show in l.a why is debbie on crow
the first artist in l.a
it's not to me it's not an accident it's
not nihilistic well i'm not doing i'm
not doing it for second place so i'm
glad i'm the first
yeah that's that's right that's right
and and
for me it it has a lot of deep meaning
in the field of
what you know what you're doing what
you're bringing to our world
um and where your visionary mind is at
with
with things and music production and
also with
the synthesis of where we can create
because we talk about this a lot on the
program is like
becoming mimetic gods becoming the
world's best animators becoming the
world's best anthology and documentary
creators where
there's just this there's this everyone
comes to simulation to be able to
package the most complex thing like
crispr cast nine how can you package
that into a one minute
video and send that out to a billion
people around the planet in a way that
really excites them on an animation
level but the animation
requires the music and that's why this
is
there's so many things to collaborate on
and create on i mean
it's it's endless to what we're to be
doing oh yeah no we're we
lit renaissance time like we're so lucky
and people like oh this is such a i'm
like
yeah there's a lot of hard things but
like i just try to focus on how exciting
this [ __ ] is like this is insane
yes like and i know for a fact like in
50 years they're gonna look back on this
time and be like
these kids were so lucky like they had
it they had they were at the
like the ground floor of like this
there's one more
layer on top of i think where we're
going which is that it's going to become
more
of the like kind of mixed reality
creative and when
when that happens what's going to happen
is the same way that we use the devices
right now to manipulate the eq
and this evernote file and the tricaster
and entering the videos
it's just going to be a little bit more
kind of like in the mixed reality
environment just kind of like
click drag drop sort add creative spin
add coloration um voice using voice
uh you know doing the location
agnosticism with talking to other people
on the creative project
delivering that to billions of people
with the click of a
fast faster with higher bandwidths
neural links
all this type of stuff so there's kind
of the next layer
which you gave the computer information
technology layer
the mixed reality neural link
augmentation layer is like kind of next
well and and one how crazy is that going
to be it's like i feel like maybe
by the time we kind of burn out um all
these new tools we've just gotten and
you know like we're
they're still kind of in this awkward
stage we're still like learning how to
maximize them but
you know who knows by that time yeah
like if like we were saying on the phone
too last night if if we really get to
that like they plug you in and you're
like in the matrix
there's no air there's no limitation on
your ears like what the [ __ ] is that
music going to sound like
and who gets to make that music complete
body orgasm
who knows yeah like what is that what is
it who even knows how
and what tools are you going to use to
design that music like
man who knows but um it is exciting too
but i'm almost like
i kind of want that to like i want a lot
of time with these new tools like i kind
of
like i hope that doesn't have a too soon
because i don't have to relearn
everything like okay
now we're done with speakers now it's
all about like getting into this virtual
reality and like building the music that
exists in this space like that'll be
uh yeah i don't know i'm j yeah yeah i
already did enough work i wanna i just i
just hope this lasts for a little longer
like give me 10 years with this and then
we can do whatever you want
said the truck driver yeah yeah yeah oh
god
oh the truck driver's nude it's gonna be
rough so we'll figure it out yeah
being adaptive is the one of the highest
traits of
biological success so we need to adapt
it and i don't want to
skill and all these types of things and
i'm not afraid of it like if it did
happen tomorrow i'd be like okay let's
put on the work gloves whatever but
yes um we'll see what happens i wanna
we're
two hours in we'll kind of we'll kind of
move on on these
last couple subjects okay um so
something that's really beautiful that
um that you've
embarked on which i have also done
many times and and and due i aim to do
the three day fast monthly and it's been
a lot of fun
and and i've done one five day i haven't
done 10.
you did 10 days of just water yeah and i
think it's very beautiful
um to be able to kind of drop into
ketosis
uh burn fat um as a source of energy
basically uh do some sort of like
hardcore
autophagy inside of your body where all
these more
um pathological components
intracellularly that are
uh that are starting to be dysfunctional
yeah it can be kind of eaten up and and
and dissolved in there for
the strong survival and you related that
also to shadow which is really
interesting so
yeah so walk us down the 10-day fast
path sure okay well and it started with
a few
shorter ones and in college i did like
the
cleanse where you know you you were able
to do like lemon juice cayenne pepper
and
uh what was it syrup maple syrup so i'd
also had experience there i did that for
15 days
and we did a really slow um like
refeeding off of that so
pretty much 20 days without normal food
intake um
but that that was different and it was
fine but i think
i'm a big proponent of the water fast
just because it's crazy how it makes me
feel
um and i do think there's something
and again to each his own and i know
there's a lot of controversy on this
like i've watched documentaries where
people are like really upset about it
they're like it's so dangerous and
you're taking your life in your own
hands and all this stuff
and i think it always goes back any
anything in nutrition it always goes
back to like what works for you
and like it you know you kind of really
have to
yeah because i don't think there's a big
enough test group on most
studies to be like every human on the
planet should eat this and do this it's
like i don't know
um but microbiomes are very personalized
well
one again and i'm not i'm not an expert
this is just what works for me like
obviously consult your doctor whatever
but yeah i did i did
uh two three day water fest it was kind
of this ramp up then i did an eight day
and then eventually the ten day um and
it was amazing like it it really felt
like
i was burning off like
these old cells that like wanted
sadness and wanted alcohol and wanted me
to smoke cigarettes more and more and
like you know like
all this they wanted me to stay in the
trailer park basically you know they're
like
these little teeny pieces of like you
know they're like little
fiends you know and they they kind of
and i've heard people describe
ourselves as like one of the smallest
forms of our consciousness
because they do have an impact on us and
they do crave things
and yeah killing all those guys off was
like
it and i you know it's a continuous
process not like it's some silver bullet
and i'm done
i'm cured or anything but i think for me
personally it was like super beneficial
um yeah i just shed it a lot of like
weight and
garbage and and and bad
feelings and like i just shed a bunch of
crap um
and uh yeah you know there's this talk
in my
um in my family and like
we we kind of talk about like yeah
there's this thing we're trying to move
out of especially with my cousin tyler
we speak about this stuff a lot and it's
like
we're trying to move out of this this
space and get to the you know get to the
better zone
um and and it's almost been described as
like you know there's some kind of
curse or this repeating you know almost
like the um
the the whole bruce lee dragon thing you
know like
your family's stuff kind of follows you
you know there's like this
and science calls it epigenetics okay so
there you go so i think
yeah and we so there's that and and just
in just my own past even just you know
like she's trying to burn off my own
past
let alone like the curse of my family i
love the way that you talk about
literally the cells themselves having
some sort of very like micro level
consciousness where there's this
proclivity for them to want like
cigarettes or alcohol and depression and
sadness
depression because well because all
those chemicals that come out of your
brain like
feed that desire of those cells and like
yeah they definitely have
addiction or you know or like they have
a need for so whatever so yeah
it it's uh it's yeah that's a that's a
whole other
level of all that stuff and it's tricky
because yeah it's it's just weird i mean
we're walking around in these like
animal meat sacks like it's so straight
like our
existence is like so bizarre to me you
know i feel like it makes so much more
sense if we were like this
i don't know like energy creature or
like or even a robot would make more
sense to me like this weird like
yeah it's interesting that our
physicality is what it is but um which
is funny because a lot of spiritual
people say that well i
am just spirit or i am sure i am just
that energy and that this physical
meat vehicle is something that is you
know it's funny because i always say
simultaneity you have to
be the biological meat suit and you have
to be the
spirit in in the essence of the soul
sure and if you kind of
synthesize those two that's really where
you can
kind of knock home runs out well yeah
one it's interesting too like in a
really concrete way like if you
if you gain control over your body you
know you see those people
being able to you know have a lot more
ease with succeeding in the other venues
like if you you know like
like i've never seen like a super you
know uh jacked guy that like can't
you know um achieve you know running
down the block or like do you know i
don't know like he
there's there's success in that space or
or even maybe it's not even super
jackass i want to get this right like
if you can control yeah even okay like
let's use your example of um
like the kind of guru person okay so
maybe they're not like super fitness
person but it's like
they gain control of their body and that
allows
their full brain space to
you know whatever else they're trying to
delve into and i think that's huge
i mean even in simple stuff like i make
sure i'm really comfortable
when i'm working i make sure like just
anything i can do to
to like hoard my brain space so i can
put all of it into the music
that's right it's a it's it does it adds
up like it really adds up in the weird i
mean
it's that's why the phone has to be
powered off it has to be put away all
that stuff
all that stuff there's all kinds of
things and people have all kind yeah and
like i love how sports
you know so many sports people have like
all these little ceremonies and stuff
that they do and like these
superstitions and like
whatever it takes man like whatever it
takes for you to protect your brain
space and your focus so when you're out
there your
peak performance level like do it like
absolutely
fasting's totally in that sphere so yeah
give it
give it give it a go um you know try and
and uh go against the cultural norm of
eating three meals a day
trying fast for a day if you've never
tried it before uh it's really awesome
it's worth the shot
it doesn't work it doesn't open into
burning fat it might not work for you so
just give it a give it a go exactly
um we'll we'll
we'll save a vast majority of this for
when we
um sit down again on the program because
we've we talked about this with evan
for like two hours uh yesterday on the
show specifically about
consciousness yeah um so when we get you
back on especially as we do more like
group dynamic
settings on these discussions um in
general what would you say
you think is the nature of consciousness
yeah so
huge question um basically what i've
been doing now and this will be like
easy to do like it's a shorter answer so
we don't
spend a bunch more time but at the
moment
right now i'm using my consciousness or
like using that
when i'm feeling like i'm being very
conscious right like when i'm like
really engaged or whatever
um and and i'm kind of focused there
it's all about romance so like i boiled
it down
and i've really been focusing on that
like probably would you say that that's
analogous to flow
romance and so the way i define so the
way i define romance for myself
um at least at the moment and like how
i'm trying to
like explore with it or kind of
experiment with
that idea is it's all about an idea that
i'm
gonna remember this moment so trying to
make something
um cultivate you know uh an activity or
you know especially when i'm locked in
and making music that's obviously
something i hope i'm gonna remember
those moments so
like pushing myself to be conscious
enough to the point where it's
like really landing into my like hard
drive and staying
there um and i think
it's kind of like i'm i'm playing with
it a lot and i'm realizing it's like a
feeling
but it's also um it's also like a task
you know it's like you have to kind of
actively
hold that um you know there's a lot of
stuff to it and
in um the main times that happens to me
is like when i'm singing is a really fun
time because i'm like way out
in the space like just trying to grab
the perfect phrasing
and and it's just enjoyable you know
like i'm just hearing the music through
my headphones and i'm in this like quiet
room and it's
and i and again and it's just kind of
and i usually like sing in loops so like
i'll sing the same phrase over and over
until it's just perfect
and then i'll save that and then i'll do
it again and do it again layer it
and then move on and like kind of do it
in steps and so it's like this really
like
slow you know take it at your own pace
and just really like getting into it
um and letting that perfect take like
just come to me and not like fight for
it or something
um and then obviously romance and um
you know like with another person like
that stuff to me is like so
it's so huge like it's like it's it's
because because i think
we're all gonna die right like the grim
reaper is over here but i think a lot of
people forget he's also like running at
you
every time you're forgetting something
it's kind of like you're dying in this
other direction
and so i've always been interested in
trying to combat that and try to be like
no no no wait a second like
i want to live in a way where not only
i'm getting these accomplishments done
but i'm
i'm remembering them in the i'm i'm
giving them enough
meaning or importance to me that
i'm not just giving it away to the to
the devil or you know giving it away to
the grim reaper like oh just whatever
it's not even important like so it's in
a sense it's cultivating such
romance with your moment-to-moment
existence
right which a lot of peak performance
people call flow like you're in so
immersed
in that that romantic moment to moment
beingness
artistic expression that you're doing
yeah you're so in that flow state
that then conscious experience rather
than
becoming something that is like
stressful or becoming something that you
forget
is something that you basically
everything is saved
as a really beautiful easier said than
easier than done but
this is the essence of where you were
kind of taking potentially
some of the thoughts on the nature of
consciousness for sure yeah yeah so
we'll and like so and instead of and i
guess the reason i
gave you that answer is because that's
what i'm doing with it now
and maybe like you said maybe next time
we talk we can go more into like
the different things consciousness can
be for me but at the moment i'm really
trying to just
have that be my number one yes um kind
of
uh attention to it or imagine a world
where
everybody has a deep profound sense of
cultivated romance and flow with their
artistic process
yeah that's indeed stuff right there
well and i think i think it would be
it'd be great for a lot of reasons i
mean i think
the more people take their time
um seriously and the more they care
about
the more you care about stuff the more
you feel like you have something to lose
the more you feel like you have
something to lose the less
risky dangerous mean you know the less
you're just going to flop around and be
like oh well screw that guy boom boom
boom i'm going to go
go to war no no you're like whoa whoa
whoa this is all really important like
we got to really
we got to really cherish all this yes
like that's such a i think that's
going to be yeah and again easier said
than done
and like yeah you know and i've had this
conversation and the last thing i said
i've had this conversation for a lot of
people with like
you know do you ever think we're going
to get to a world where there's like
sans war like where we can actually
abandon that as an institution and stuff
yeah and stop blowing each other up
so many people are like no way and i'm
like come on man like you have why
believe in world peace in order to get
well and i think and i think i think why
is it so crazy to believe like we're
still gonna have
problems we're just gonna have new
different problems that are
like you know way less exploding people
probably
which would be really nice because like
that shit's got we got to cut that out
like we got
you know we abolished slavery yes right
yes i know we still have all these
problems
moved our ethics more and more towards
maximizing well-being and flourishing
and it's
yeah and it's gonna take and that's the
other thing they're like well i don't
see it happening in our lifetime i'm
like okay that's fair
but the idea that it could happen like
we have to i think we got to push for it
because yeah maybe it's not gonna happen
maybe it's gonna take ten thousand years
for it to happen but
shouldn't that be like such a thing we
get rid of it just it doesn't work
it's a broken institution just get rid
of it indigenous people
focus a lot on in different cultures
around the planet on something like a
seventh generation principle
so and so if you really do think on a
world peace level trying to get
everybody to a state of where their
nourish their their roots are fully
nourished with their basic needs so that
they can actualize their
states of cultivated romance and flow
and fruits into the world
then we can more easily attain some sort
of like a world peace on
a seventh generational level so it's
really about the architectures that we
implement in this 2020 2021
on and beyond level that kind of ensure
that the future trajectory is most
benevolent and fruitful
well i think it's you know and i think
if it doesn't pass the love test
it's not going to be sustainable you
know like if it's not coming from a
place of love and
you're you're dust and i think um since
we're wrapping up um
i wanted to tell the story about so
we're going to end the the
we are we're going to outro with uh your
song called
dreams yeah and and that's coming out
that's gonna so this is like what we're
gonna say what are we saying this is oh
this is the world premiere
the world's premiere what's going on
right now
no um but it's coming out um i'm gonna
drop it on youtube
on tuesday sorry i just gotta get sounds
uh
comes out tuesday just on youtube um
there'll be you know there'll be another
little teaser
with it to promote it um and uh
yeah i don't know when i think i might
let this one ride and just drop it with
the album
but a few people are on me they're like
nah man like get this thing out on spot
get it out everywhere like asap so i
might do it that way we'll see but i'll
you know oh
if you if you follow me like that's the
other thing follow my stuff and then
i'll keep you updated yeah so all right
beautiful let's uh we'll
we'll outro so we have um
we have guys we like it's a awesome
epic convo like just absolutely
i loved it likewise yeah absolutely i
i'm
i just i'm ridiculously impressed with
the you know
when all everything on the journey
level everything on the way that the
gifts are being actualized and
everything on
like your your super high level
awareness about like exponential
technologies and where things are being
taken in that
front so guys all of zeb's links
are in the bio below so in the
bio you can find the spotify link highly
recommend that
youtube you can watch a bunch of the
good videos content as well with the
music
and then also his instagram page so you
can find those links go and follow him
support him subscribe follow on youtube
and give the content to listen and then
let us know your thoughts in the bio
below not or in the comments below let
us know your thoughts about not only the
episode but let us know your thoughts
about
zeb's music so go and check it out maybe
drop a comment about the music we'd love
to hear from you yeah i always like
feedback for sure
yeah love to hear from you and then uh
keep supporting all of the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
people in your communities that are
trying to build the more beautiful
future are hard to know as possible
so support them help them flourish you
can find all of simulation our show's
links in the bio below
go and build the future execute your
dreams
manifest them into the world we love you
very much thank you for tuning in
are you ready for the last story i'm
gonna tell them about the song
okay seb is going to tell you about the
song
and then we are going to play dreams and
then
end the stream okay so this one's really
special to me right so
um i'm like head over heels to this girl
like like and it's really strange
because like
we're not hanging out a lot she's super
busy so it's like kind of this
disjointed relationship but we're like
super
into each other um didn't work out but
it was like the kind of apex of that
this like and it was so weird because
it was all this emotion that wasn't like
there was nowhere to put it because we
weren't able to see each other because
we were so busy
um so we we were dreaming about each
other a lot
wow right and i finally kind of bring it
up and it you know i felt a little corny
or whatever but i was like hey you know
i got a dream she's like that's funny
like i did
i've been dreaming about you too and um
and basically and i'll never forget how
she said that she says
you can't tell me because my family
believes my family not me but my family
believes that if you tell someone about
your dreams then it won't
or your dream especially if it's about
them it's not going to come true oh wow
and so the whole crux of this song is
that i was having so many of them
that i figured okay maybe i can tell you
about a few of the dreams because all's
i need is one of the dreams to come true
and then we're
we're good you know then everything's
perfect and again it fell apart and it
didn't quite work out but
um i think that was a moment like that
was very much a moment of
feeling just like overdosed on romance
yeah you know like in that time it was
like there was so much of it
and and it was all kind of imaginary you
know because we didn't get it we didn't
get to see each other
in like the physical like barely at all
like we probably
were like in the same room six times
over this relationship like very few
times
but it was you know the
visionary the vision you know the vision
of it was there and it was so
real that it's like i didn't even need
the other part
so that that and i think this song like
kind of good
yeah so this one's like super special to
me this is this is probably my favorite
song on the album so
i'm glad we're premiering it world
premiere right here wow
so feel the vibes i love that it's
amount of meaning
there's a lot of romance in this one
this one's dripping with it so i love it
all right everyone much love enjoy
dreams
it's gonna chill by the fire that's
right
[Music]
[Music]
so
we're in the mountains of town
it's just the two of us
there's no one around for miles in any
direction you can point me
[Music]
i guess it was me there was only
i guess
[Music]
that i could
just right like you've been reading
my mind i know the air is freezing cold
damn it's so good
champagne in the snow
we'll get everything we need when we get
it
and i was just around the time that i
realized i was dreaming
and i know you told me not to tell you
if i think about you when i'm sleeping
cause then the dream won't come
that i could tell you
you